day of public hearings it is Thursday
March 4th before I get going um I'll
I'll do the announcements that need to
be done reminding members to mute and
turn off electronic devices if you're
using them um as or if you're intending
to use a keyboard speak
clearly soft voices are hard to be heard
and these microphones pick up sound
pretty well we hope let us know U for
those of you attending by Zoom if you
can't hear us we will be muted during a
lunch break I am not exactly sure when
that will her based on the hearings this
morning um there is a signin sheet which
stopped expect which stopped this
morning at 8 o'clock for today's
hearings um you are capable of speaking
after that if you have logged on raise
your hand when we get to that point in
the meeting and the signning sheet will
be open for the rest of the day until
11:59 so after you speak you can sign up
in regards to this meeting itself as
chair of the house election law
committee I find that dueing the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic and an
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuing to executive order
20204 this body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills R committee and scheduled in
the house calendar today um while an
executive session may be held during the
day I do not expect that to occur today
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously however the
emergency order I'm confirming that all
members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary particip in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access to information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar of the
general Board website the notice for
this meeting complies with house rules
and RSA 91a and anyone who has a problem
access to the meetings you call
271-3600 or email HCS LGE lg.
state. Us in the event public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and schedu all votes being
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote um and before we take
the roll call attendants we will do a
pledge but Pam if you're on I understand
that there has been an executive order
so that motions to adjourn do not need
to be by roll call so I just wanted to
put that out there because that's my
plan for today all right before we get
going if you can rise
and to the flag of the United States of
America and to the repblic
stands one nation God indivisible
liberty and justice for all thank you so
much everybody um and I will take the
role at this time representative
McDonald here representative Fudan here
representative Sweeny here
representative Hayward here
representative Mooney here
representative ter roian here
representative Barry here representative
Rowan here representative quy here
representative Wells here representative
Cody here representative Ward here
representative
bod representative
Sandler thought I saw here thank you
good morning representative HR here
representative PL
I'm here by myself in my home office
good morning thank you to the rules I'm
letting that by yourself I've never
understood it
anyways representative
Freda I know I saw her
on representative
feda all right um representative Hamlet
you're muted yeah representative TL
you're muted so sorry I didn't think I
was yes I am here in my home and my son
is in another room all right and
representative behead president thank
you very much
everybody all right the first bill that
we have on for this morning is HB
61 this is relative to absentee
voting and
allowing for the partial processing of
absentee ballots prior to election day
uh representative Rong is the prime
sponsor and has signed up to speak
representative Rong I apologize I have
not already elevated you
to speak but you are should be with us
now and if you unmute welcome to the
election
launch thank you very much can everyone
hear me okay welcome all right good
morning everyone um I come before you to
introduce House Bill 61 this bill allows
New Hampshire voters to cast their vote
by absentee ballot even when there is no
stated excuse this bill also allows
municipalities to partially pre-process
absentee ballots before Election Day
first I want to address the
pre-processing of absentee ballots
making this option permanent was a
request made to me by maram Max's Town
moderator in fact a couple of
co-sponsors of this bill both
Republicans are moderators or
co-moderators for their
towns and they are in strong support as
well allowing partial pre-processing of
absentee ballots is a bipartisan Common
Sense option for those municipalities
who want to better manage their workload
of election day it proved to be a life
saver for marac as it allowed us to
efficiently manage a huge uptick in
absentee ballots while maintaining the
Integrity of the
process we also learned from the
November election that expanding
absentee balloting absentee voting
encourages more citizens to participate
in fact
84,4 N9 votes were cast in the November
election breaking the previous record
for voter turnout growth in absentee
value balloting drove this growth as we
saw
26,27 of those votes cast by absentee or
32% of the total in 2016 only 10% of
Voters cast their vote by
absentee how is this jump in voter
participation explained yes fear of
covid kept many people home and opting
to take advantage of the executive order
allowing absentee voting how I believe
it was more than this there are people
who just avoid interacting with
strangers Co or not or a fear of
procedure or building that they are
unfamiliar with or they may be
intimidated walking through the gauntlet
of candidates and campaign standing
outside the polls all of us have
campaigned and I'm sure as we're out
there holding our signs and and greeting
voters some just cower it's it's very
intimidating to them and some just
decide not to go through that and stay
home these folks feel more confident
voting by absentee in the familiar
environment of their home but until the
covid excuse they just opted not to vote
at all so this bill is really about
Liberty the state of being free within
Society from control or oppressive
restrictions imposed by government why
shouldn't a citizen be free to vote by
absentee why do they need an excuse why
should they have to meet one of the
governments stated excuses in order to
exercise their voting rights back in the
day when I was working juggling the
schedule of three kids and a home I
often wondered why the guy next door got
to vote at his convenience in his home
because of business travel but I did not
why was I denied that right why do we
deny that right to tens of thousands of
granite
Staters now you may hear that absentee
Val absentee voting is dict dictated by
the New Hampshire Constitution allow me
to read to you part one article 11 of
our
constitution quote the general court
shall provide by law for voting by
qualified voters who at the time of the
banial or state elections or of the
primary elections therefore or of City
elections or of town elections by
official ballot are absent from the city
or town uh of which they are inhabitants
or who by reason of physical disability
or unable to vote in person in the
choice of any officer or officers to be
elected or upon any question submitted
at such election please note the first
seven words of that
article the general court shall provide
by law the general court shall provide
by law the general court is US folks we
are the general court we pass the laws
that govern voting let's use use our
constitutional power to pass a law to
allow all New Hampshire citizens the
Liberty to vote by absentee not just for
those with an excuse now you will hear
speculation that expanding the right to
absentee voting will cause problems
increased risk of fraud increased
activity by special interest groups Etc
that risk already exists whether we
allow no excuse absentee voting or not
we have the power to address that now
let's not allow that risk to paralyze us
from moving forward already 2third of US
states allow no excuse absentee voting
New Hampshire should not be left behind
after after all of all the states we
value Liberty let's put it into action
by recommending ought to pass on HB 61
and I would be very happy to answer any
questions you may have thank you
thank you representative questions from
members in the room representative Brian
thank you
m are you aware uh of the wording in RSA
6571 that uh describes the eligibility
for voting absentee right now and that
includes an employment obligation which
also is defined employment is defined as
the care of children and in adults with
or without compensation
you need to be jealous of your
neighbor ability
vente
the I'm I couldn't really hear I think I
got the gist of your question uh yes I'm
aware of it but when I was raising
children I didn't have that option but
many people don't they you know they
just want that allowance they don't know
what election day is going to bring to
them or what's going to happen in their
lives is there going to be a football
practice to get to and many people
interpret that as um you know maybe
caring for an infant where you have to
Pro provide their primary needs but
running people running kids around to
practices or different classes um they
may not think of it and I think a lot of
people to be honest don't read the rsas
I think if they realize that they have
the right to vote by absentee they'll
take advantage of it they're not going
to go and search and find out all those
specific
reasons other questions from committee
members follow up representative from
Brian thank you
chair I'm not aware of what the
tradition is for uh and the situation in
every Community is but in my community
when I campaign or when I my sign I've
never had an interaction with a voter
that causes them to power and feares
this have you ever seen this in your own
experience power and fear
oh AB I
me for coming
out um well well thank you for the
question oh I absolutely see people
avoid the candidates and the campaign
signs they walk on the other side of the
sidewalk but honestly I know people that
just don't vote they don't want to walk
through the gauntlet um you know we
think we're doing a great job we think
oh we're meeting the voters we're
helping them most people people don't
like that they don't want to be
approached they don't want to be talked
to or greeted by people they don't know
they just want to go in do their Duty
and get out and those people that that
don't even want to subject subject
themselves to that they stay
home this bill would allow them it's
like if you if you don't want to go
through that if you don't want to walk
past strangers greeting you if you'd
rather just stay home that's okay you
can still vote in the privacy of your
own
home thank you representative Barry so
have some further questions about can
you hear me all right representative R
yeah it's a little hard hearing people
in the room but but please go ahead
thank let me just interrupt I actually
representative R you I thought were
softer on the speaking this morning than
what we've had in the past do any other
members in the room think the volume is
lower than it has been in the past or
not a a little I think the volume
setting is a little different than it
has been so if everybody could speak up
a little bit that would be great
represent thank Madam
chairman representative R make follow
with representative' Bryant's questions
he makes some statements about voters
being intimidated and being approached
in the polls but that's electioneering
it's it's already illegal in the state
of New Hampshire to harass voters or
approach voters in the polls the the
moderators have great discretion in
setting up where where people can
campaign stand and we have to balance it
I think you make a good point but we
have to balance this against People's
First Amendment right to have political
speech it is in fact the most protected
speech in their constitution so I'm I'm
just wondering is if if this is the
number one concern for you shouldn't we
be addressing electioneering laws and
where how we're setting up polling
locations and not just going after
absentee Bing I've never heard this is a
this is a new one for me I've never
heard this one as the perhaps valid um I
use well thank you for the question I I
use as an example I I think if we get
out there and we talk to people in our
communities you're going to find people
they just don't want to go through that
they don't want to walk past the signs
and people saying good morning we don't
think it's harassment when I greet a
voter at the polls I say thank you for
coming out thank you for coming to vote
um I don't think it's harassment but
they do a lot of people don't want
strangers and they consider me a
stranger they may not they don't know me
personally they don't want me greeting
them and there are some people that just
want to vote in their own home and I
don't know why we allow some people to
do that and then we forbid other people
to do that I think all people should
have the right to vote in the privacy of
their home if we're going to allow some
people to do it we should allow everyone
to do
it to me it's an issue of Liberty I
should have the same rights of someone
who happen to schedule business travel
on Election
Day thank you is there any commit member
attending electronically there a
question for representative
R
we okay thank you all very much for your
attention and for your questions I I
appreciate it and thank you madam chair
representative Lan did you have a
question or
not no no all right
okay anybody else with a question before
we left representative before you go I
didn't do my final do you have a
question all right I'm not seeing thank
you very muches all right thank you
thank you very much all right also
signed up to speak on this bill is
Cordell
Johnson thank you madam ch um good to
see you and all the committee
members Cordell Johnston representing
the new Municipal
Association and uh we are in support uh
specifically of sections 7 through 10 of
this bill we do not have a position on
sections one through six uh one through
six are the provisions for no excuse
absentee voting um our support is the
sections that deal with pre-processing
of absentee ballots uh as those of you
who have um have served as election
officials know the processing of
absentee ballots is a fairly tedious
process uh that ordinarily takes place
on Election Day at the polls and it
takes the attention of the moderator and
the clerk and the ballot clerks away
from other things uh other duties that
they
have and uh at a uh at a state election
especially a presidential election it
can take several hours um depending on
the size of the municipality to process
the absentee ballots so either either it
happens during polling
hours uh which disrupts the uh the other
activities that are going on or it has
to be put off until the end uh of the
day and it makes a an extremely long day
that much longer during uh the fall
elections the um uh municipalities
polling places were allowed to
pre-process absentee ballots uh on a on
on a day before the election
where uh election officials would open
the outer envelope of the absentee
ballot read the name of the person uh
who had submitted it make sure
everything was in order and make a mark
on the checklist uh so that when the
final processing was done on Election
Day everything went much faster much
more
smoothly um the the
pre-processing was done in public it was
uh publicly po posted uh people were
allowed to be there and challenged just
as as they would on Election Day and
everyone who had anything to do with
this process thought that it worked very
well and one of the benefits that hadn't
really been anticipated was when um when
election officials discovered that there
was a a ballot that had not been
properly signed uh the affidavit was not
properly they were able to contact the
voter before election day and tell them
there was a problem and if the voter was
in town the voter could come in and uh
fix the problem so their ballot would be
counted in my town um and I am the
moderator in my town we identified six
uh absentee ballots that were not
properly completed and each of those six
voters was able to come in and fix the
problem if we've been doing the
processing on um on Election Day that
would not have worked so this um House
Bill 61 sections 7 through 10 make that
uh make that ability to prepr
pre-process permanent and uh we very
strongly support that and again are
neutral on sections one through six
thank you very much thank you Mr johnon
is there anyone here who has a
question Mr
Johnson representative to rosan thank
you madam chair thank you Mr Johnson for
taking my question prior to the 2020
election cycle were you aware of any
problems with doing the pre-processing
of aeny ballots on Election Day where
they were there any problems doing
that do during the processing on
Election Day um yeah I would say there
the the main problem was how much time
it took um in in uh larger uh larger
towns and larger City Wards there were
reports of uh election officials having
to work on uh processing the absentee
ballots uh way past the time that the
polls closed so that they ended up uh uh
finally counting the ballots and Rec
reconciling the ballots at one or two
o'clock in the morning uh and um a large
part of that problem was the need to
process the absentee ballot in September
and November that problem really went
away
way anyone else with a question here in
the room how about anybody attending
electronically
questions Mr johnsone I I do have a
question uh there is currently an
emergency order in place that allow
pre-processing for local elections which
are really beginning the majority of
them will be next week do you know how
many communities have it to take
advantage of the preprocessing for those
elections no I don't I I would guess
that it's relatively small uh because as
you know turnout at Town elections is is
much lower than turnout at State
elections in my town for example I
checked with the clerk last week and she
said we had 12 absentee bot
applications as opposed to in the fall I
think we had uh something like
700 so um in our town there's no need to
do the pre-processing for Town elections
at least not this year it's really uh
it's really an issue at the state
elections in in the even number of
years okay great anything else for Mr
Johnston
hary oh I'm sorry Speak Up
representative
fedus
thank you for hearing um I'm in Ward 7
in Manchester and I found it invaluable
to counted ah had to to had to do the
absentee ballots in
advance we had
hundreds thank
you anybody else with a question for Mr
Johnstone
I'm not seeing any um thank you for
coming this morning also signed up to
speak this morning is the co-sponsor of
the bill representative tersi I'm hoping
I pronounced that right welcome to the
election
law thank you very much Madam chairwoman
you pronounced it perfectly my name is
Laura tersi and I represent Hillsboro 35
which is Nashua Ward 8 I'm testifying
today in support of hp61 as a co-sponsor
and in particular to advocate for the
partial pre-processing of absentee
ballots since 2016 I have worked as a
poll worker for a number of elections in
nsha in addition to serving a two-year
term as award selectman from 2017 to9 I
can tell you from experience that the
people who work our elections do it
because they believe in the Democratic
process and want to give back to our
community but if you've never worked a
full election day I'm not sure you can
understand the physical stamina and
energy that is required in naswa we
welcome voters from 6:00 a.m. to 8:00
p.m. that means our po workers arrive at
5: and spend hours on their feet or in
metal folding chairs Manning the
checklist and assisting voters in
addition to processing absentee ballots
after the doors close the work is just
beginning as ballots are counted and
paperwork completed where you need to be
sharp accurate and attentive to details
often not finishing until well after
midnight the majority of our pole
workers are senior citizens and
recruiting workers has become more and
more difficult as the work is physically
and mentally exhausting taking just this
one task the partial pre-processing of
absentee ballots and allowing election
officials to do some of that work in
advance takes a small burden off these
workers who already are responsible for
so much on the day of the election
anything that allows a person to be more
arrested and complete the task at hand
accurately is a good thing for our
election process we saw that it worked
in the 2020 elections and I encourage
you to keep it I'll conclude there and I
just thank you for considering my
remarks today thank you thank you very
much for your testimony any members in
the room of the committee that have a
question for the representative anybody
online with a
question speak
up I I have a question uh and I
perhaps I should have asked it if
representative run but It sped to my
mind do you know whether the changes to
this bill are exactly the same as those
that were made last session to allow for
preprocessing in
November thank you for the question um I
do know that I had a conversation with
representative rung when we were
discussing me getting onto this bill and
I believe yes it is the same process as
was uh put forward last year thank thank
you anybody
else all right I'm not seeing any thank
you very much for your participation
this morning um I also have a sign up to
speak Mr Barnes but I am not seeing him
in attendance if Mr Barnes is online
could he please raise his hand and I
will be happy to have him join our
meeting and I'm not seeing him so at
this time I note that deputy secretary
scanland is has his hand raised to speak
to this Bill Good morning Deputy
scanon
welcome H good morning Madam chair
members of the committee I'm David
scanland deputy secretary of state um
and you know have a kind of a split uh
position on this particular piece of
legislation I will start off with the no
excuse absentee B uh B OT portion of
this and state our opposition to that as
we have done in the past uh for such
bills um the first issue is the
Constitutional hurdle and you know I
know representative Rong uh mentioned
that earlier and she is right that it's
that the sentence in article 11 part one
of the Constitution that applies to this
does say that the general court shall
provide by law for voting by qualified
voters at the time of
banial or state election or of the
primary elections therefore or of City
elections or town elections by official
ballot are absent that's a very specific
term and then it goes on to say or who
by physical disability are unable to
vote in person so there are two specific
reasons in the Constitution for which a
person can vote absentee if you look at
the history of how that the uh the
absentee and the disability Provisions
entered into the Constitution at the
earlier part of the L the 1900s you will
see that those were very intentional
additions to the Constitution uh by the
state
legislature so you know we believe that
that that that provision in the
Constitution precludes just a a blanket
no excuse absentee balloting
uh process in addition to that though
opening up the uh absentee voting to
anybody for any reason does create some
issues and could potentially Place some
burdens and pressures on voters that do
not currently exist and we saw some of
this uh in the last election where uh uh
concern over covid was considered a
disability and so it broadly opened up
the issue of absente voting we did see
organizations political parties and
candidates use that uh to uh uh um
broadly Target voters to encourage them
to vote that way and you know further
raises concerns of uh of management of
absentee ballots by organizations
parties or or campaigns um you may have
heard the term ballot harvesting uh
which has been an issue in other states
that is a real concern and uh and you
know any effort to uh allow no excuse
absentee voting also has to address
those issues whether they are real or
perceived um they are a major
concern moving on to the uh
pre-processing of absentee
ballots um that the the that provision
as it was applied in the state elections
in 2020 was very well received by local
election officials uh it did have
significant benefits in allowing the
workload uh to be spread out um
additionally as was mentioned earlier uh
it gave election officials the
opportunity to contact voters where uh
there were deficiencies in the absentee
uh uh ballot mostly the affidavits where
the voters could be contacted uh address
those concerns and make sure that their
ballots were counted on the day of the
election
that was a tremendous benefit so we are
favorable to that provision as it was
applied uh uh in the 2020 elections
however I will say that in in this bill
in section 10 on line uh line 20
starting on line 20 on page seven uh it
says the moderator or his or her design
May begin the processing of absentee
ballots prior to the opening of the
polls provided that the clerk shall Post
in an appropriate place um and prior to
election day notice in time and place of
processing that is something that is new
uh the way I read that language it would
allow the processing of absentee before
the election there's no time frame
doesn't say the morning of the election
before the polls open uh it doesn't say
the week prior it just says that they
make that absentee ballots may be
processed prior to the election and we
are very much opposed to that and do not
think that that is necessary or
appropriate um in this piece of
legislation um with that I will end
there Madam chair and I would be happy
to answer any
questions thank you questions from
committee members in the room
representative toosan thank you madam
chair thank you Deputy scanland for
taking the
question uh in the past prior to the
2020 election um where they weren't uh
actually pre-processed prior to the
election if there was an anomaly or a
problem with one of the ballots uh was
there still the ability for the somebody
um supervisor checklist or somebody in
the
town to reach out to the voter to to get
a an answer to
the the anomaly or is it that simply the
vote simply thrown out under how we've
done it prior to 202
prior to 2020 if there was an issue with
a a an absentee ballot uh there would be
a limited opportunity for the voter to
be contacted but but in practice uh it
was probably not exercised very often uh
because of the tremendous workload that
takes place uh on the day of the
election by election officials and the
moderator especially in in general
elections um and general elections where
there's a president uh on the ballot um
the there just isn't time and and the
moderators have been asking for a
process uh like occurred um during the
2020 election for some time before the
2020 election and before covid um it you
know it has been recognized as an area
that uh needs some leave and
so the co situation forced us to do it
for the last election cycle uh it was
positive it worked well and uh and I I
think it was a very useful tool for the
moderators thank you other questions
from committee members in the
room questions from people in attendance
representative BL members thank you yes
thank you madam chair um you mentioned
concern about ballot harvesting um was
there any inkling or anything that
happened in this past election that
caused you any concern in that area or
is that coming from other
states thank you for the question
represent Lane the we know that that
there have been issues in other states
uh with that practice and we also know
that the campaigns uh have become very
sophisticated in the way in the way they
deal with absentee ballots and there
have been major efforts to identify who
potential absentee voters are uh these
organizations that are not affiliated
with the state or or the municipalities
send mailings to those individuals in
many cases making it look like they are
mailings from a government entity
encouraging people to vote by
absentee and um and uh in 2020
specifically uh that that whole process
was ramped up even more to where uh uh
where these groups were out there uh
sending mailings uh using social media
uh and other uh ways of contacting
voters uh letting them know that voting
was easy and you could attend their you
know their voter uh their voter help
site and uh you know they would have all
the help that they would need to make
sure that their absentee ballots were uh
uh applied for received
and and delivered back and so I can see
from my vantage point I can see that
this could certainly go in that
direction uh if we don't have controls
in place uh if we Implement uh a no
excuse absentee Bing uh balloting
law uh can I have a followup please sure
um
so the but our current law requires you
to either mail it in yourself or deliver
it yourself to the state so isn't that a
safeguard for ballot
harvesting our our current law um places
the burden on the voter uh the
responsibility on the voter to request
their absentee ballot fill it out uh and
mail it in and make sure that it gets
delivered to the clerk that has changed
slightly within the last six or eight
years where we have introduce the
concept of a Delivery Agent where now
for the first time a voter is able to uh
uh uh convey that responsibility to get
their ballot to the clerk to another
individual um and that is part of this
process of opening the door up to that
type of activity where you know if we
continue to expand the the definition of
Delivery Agent and and you can see the
last few elections that has has been uh
that has been attempted um we're
starting to to create that climate
where uh we have outside groups other
than the voter that are going to attempt
and and and try to administer and manage
the absentee balloting process for
voters so you know they can remind uh
the voters that that they can vote by
absentee uh it can be made incredibly
easy for them by targeting the voter
with with pre-populated forms that they
just have to sign and and get back to
the clerk if um if these if if these uh
voters are doing it through some type of
an app uh or uh software program that is
made available to them uh these groups
might be able to determine when uh the
voter might be receiving their absentee
ballots um um there's just there are
just ways for these groups to in into
the process that up until now has been
the responsibility of the
voter further questions from committee
members I'm sorry representative
mad thank you kindly Madam chair um I
I'm trying to follow this concern I'm
first I have two questions really was is
there evidence that uh objectionable
forms what you call um harvesting
occurred in the state of New Hampshire
in the past El in the 2020 election and
I guess second does this bill expand the
definition of a delivery agent in in the
manner that you just objected to uh no
to both
questions thank you representative
pet thank you madam chair so uh Deputy
scanland um so you referred to in in the
section of about the pre-processing of
absentee
ballots um You referred to uh section 10
line 20
21 that says that uh moderator or his or
her design May begin the processing of
absentee prior to the opening of the
polls and but down below in that
paragraph in line
27 it says the partial processing of
absentee ballots prior to an election
shall occur on the Thursday Friday
Saturday or Monday prior to the date of
the election after the posting of the
checklist does that not answer your
question about um or maybe I
misunderstood but I thought you said
that it seemed to allow the moderator to
allow the pre-processing at any time but
this makes it very specific that it's uh
thank you for the the question
representative Hamlet I I agree with the
the the portion of the uh of that
section that start s on line 27 because
we are talking about the partial uh uh
pre-processing of absentee ballots uh on
the Thursday Friday Saturday or Monday
prior to the election that's fine but
but when you look at line 21 it says
something very different it says the
moderator or his or her design May begin
the processing of absentee ballots that
is that's that is doing the processing
of absente ballots not pre processing
not something that is um you know the
the activity that occurred in 2020 that
is processing absentee ballots before
the polls open and that's what we would
be vigorously opposed
to I see thank you very
much further questions from
Members representative gr thank you
madam chair um thank you for taking my
question New Hampshire has a voter ID
law are absentee ballot applicants
required to show uh an ID in order to
get the
ballot the answer to that is no there is
not a requirement to show an ID to
obtain uh an absentee ballot um in the
past the the the check there was that
the voter is required to sign the
application for an absentee ballot and
then when the absentee ballot is
returned uh there is an affidavit that
is on the envelope that contains the
absentee ballot that the voter is also
required to sign and so in in up until a
few years ago uh the moderators were
able to check the signature on the
application to make sure that it matched
the uh signature on the affidavit
envelope um there was a court case that
challenged the constitutionality of that
because moderators are not uh
professional handwriting experts and
they uh the court determined that um
that the signature comparison could no
longer be a determining Factor on
whether an absentee ballot was uh
received or not if the signature was
missing on the application that would be
on the application or the affidavit
envelope that would be reason to reject
an absentee ballot uh or if the name was
different if there were two different
people that signed the application and
the affidavit envelope that would be a
reason for
rejection unless unless the differing
signature was somebody that was
acknowledging that they were helping an
individual with a
disability so effectively there is no
check on on whether
um on absentee ballots coming in because
the sign ature matching portion of it is
no longer a tool that the moderators
have now a person that is uh requesting
an absentee ballot in person from the
clerk uh can voluntarily show their ID
to the clerk and if they do that that
that allows
for a verification of that uh
individual's absentee ballot um helping
it through the process uh when it gets
processed on the day of the election
question representative brow uh Mr
scanon would that not
then allow more ease for ballot
harvesting if if uh there's essentially
no
verification no good accurate
verification of who the voter is when
there's at when there at bot
applications uh that's a good question
represent representative gr at the
moment the respon responsibility to
receive and return an absentee ballot is
still on the voter and and under our
current laws excuse me you know the
ballot harvesting concern is uh is not
very high in my opinion it is it is when
we open it up um to no excuse where you
know anybody can uh uh you know request
an absentee ballot for any reason is
when the concern in my opinion uh grows
pretty
dramatically thank you further questions
from committee
members representative
mayad thank you madam chair I I wonder
does the Secretary of State's office
have an official publication in which it
uh discusses the facts about voter
harvesting as uh as the Secretary of
State's office understands the
problem uh the the answer is no
further questions from
Members I'm seeing none thank you very
much deput scalin for joining us on this
bill is there anybody else in attendance
on House Bill 61 who would like to
testify this
morning ra your
hand I have
Mr I'm sorry uh I probably did not do
justice to your
name welcome to election fla and you
wanted to join the discussion on House
Bill
61 thank you thank you um can I be heard
now am I on yes okay so I was going to
testify in a little bit different way
but most of what I was going to say has
already been said and I'm a former State
Rep so I know it's appreciated if things
are not repeated thank you all right so
the one thing I wanted to talk about was
um my experience on helping with early
opening of the absente ballots we I'm in
do and I was an observer of that uh that
process for three days when we did it in
do and we had people there from the
Republican party and from the Democratic
party and we were all able to hear whose
ballots were rejected it was almost
always because they hadn't signed the
inner envelope so there was uh so they
couldn't be counted I personally sent
notes to people or dropped a note off at
somebody's door or called them if I was
able to find out information to tell
them that their ballot had not been
counted and for what reason and I got
several people thanking me very ferous
for letting them know and so the early
opening is really important for people
who might make a mistake that's usually
just a clerical error and they get it
informed and then they can go in either
to the city clerk and do a new Ballot or
they can actually decide to show up on
election day and vote um to get their
vote counted so I think the early
opening is really important I would add
one other thing I wasn't going to talk
about you've asked a lot about ballot
harvesting and I also follow this issue
and I agree that ballot harvesting is
really a terrible practice and whenever
it's done it's illegal and the fact that
absentee balloting would be excuse free
really is not going to make much of a
difference because if someone's intent
if some group is intent on doing that
they can use any one of the excuses and
they can talk to everybody and say look
all you have to say is you got kids at
home so you can vote absentee ballot or
people can do all kinds of Nefarious
things what happened in 2020 shows us
that that doesn't happen in New
Hampshire because we are careful with
what we do with elections and so this
bill changes nothing about the
experience of 2020 which was all
positive so I would encourage very much
ought to pass on this Bill thank
you thank you for joining us this
morning is there anybody in the
committee room or attending
electronically on the committee that has
a
question I'm not seeing any thank you
very much thank
you I am not seeing anybody else that
wants to testify on this bill this is
the public hearing on House Bill 61 so
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill 61 House Bill 516 was noted
for public hearing in at
10:15 it is a little after
10:20 this bill is allowing voters to
vote by absentee
ballot I have signed up to speak on this
a number of people the first named
sponsor on the bill is representative
Rogers representative Rogers are you in
attendance and if you
are um I would like toot to introduce
the
bill representative Rogers I see you I'm
going to promote
you to speak
representative I'm here great thank
you hear
me thank you madam chairman can you hear
me okay we can thank you madam chairman
and members of the committee um for the
record my name is Katherine Rogers and I
represent marac district 28 conquer's
East Side um House Bill 1560 um is one
you've seen before and in fact past last
session it would allow any voter who's
qualified to vote at the state election
to vote at such election by means of an
absentee ballot otherwise known as a no
excuse absentee voting which I know you
just covered similarly in a previous
bill um and just what does this do for
the people in New Hampshire it allows
flexible alternatives for voters and
allows them to participate it allows
them to cast their ballot before
election day without an excuse um this
gives voters especially lower income
voters um methods to alternatives to go
to election day allowing them to cast
their votes and become active citizens
under the current law only voters that
have a an excuse May obtain an absentee
ballot um without an excuse um they
can't go early forcing them either to
vote an election day or in some cases to
actually lie if they want to vote about
why they need an absentee ballot um you
might ask what what purposes would they
have to vote that's not in the ballots
um I would ask you to think about
someone that works in a um a very
lowincome job or a low-paying job quite
often they're called in at the last
minute they know it's a possibility but
they don't know it's going to happen and
many people don't want to take the
chance and lie and say they're going to
be working when they don't know it but
they could get a call at an hour's
notice and not be able to go in because
they're working all day so they're in a
possibility they can't go in um they
don't know if they have a new child or
they have an elderly parent that they're
going to get sick yes there are the
exceptions for child care um or
caretaker but at the last minute so
these are people that know that there's
a possibility but they don't want to
take the chance and do what they would
perceive as a lie and say that it's
happening when in fact could wake up
election day and everything's fine and
they can go in so saying that there's no
excuse allows them that opportunity
providing voters with this flexible
alter alternative widens the base of
participation and fosters a democratic
environment in which people can exercise
their right to vote and make important
decisions um we already have voters have
excuses um like travel or sickness this
just makes it a little broader we ABS we
had that basically in this last election
when the co exception came in and we
didn't find massive fraud the Secretary
of State said we did not have harvesting
in the state and you heard if someone
wanted to really Harvest votes they
could do it with the excuses that
happening um so the cases of fraud that
happen everyone always brings that up
but we know they're minuscule in this
state and the fraud happens already with
the laws the way it is so I don't think
you're going to increase it and
statistics around the country have shown
that fraud has not broadened out there
are a number of states that do already
have um this kind of legislation this
kind of voting and their um cases of
fraud are terribly small Oregon in fact
has all mail in voting and um since 2000
there's only been 33 cases of alleged
fraud which is comes out to
0.005% um pretty small for something
that makes voting um much more Universal
and I think that's what we want is an
indust for people to vote um so how does
it work absentee voting is conducted the
exact same way that we have voting right
now it's just instead of having a place
for the excuse it's not there it's just
that they want to receive an absentee
ballot um as I said many states already
have it five states um have almost
totally Universal mailing so I'm asking
you to take um a leap of faith to go
with what you've done in the past in
fact this did pass last time pass the
house past the Senate and the Govern
decided that the co exception would
cover it um but I think we need to make
it a little broader you need to be aware
of the fact that while we might feel
comfortable not lying but stretching the
truth a little and saying that we can
can some these setion into the uh
exceptions that exist or the excuses a
lot of people out there feel very badly
about saying that just because their job
might call them in they don't want to
say they have to work because they don't
necessarily know positively they do so
they're not going to do what they think
is a lie and put that down they're going
to take the chance and if they get
called in that day and can't vote
they're going to miss the chance to vote
it might be a vote for you or I it might
be a vote for our opponents but we want
everyone to vote I think all of us here
believe in democracy and we'd love it if
we had 100% participation but it's not
for us to decide it's for those
individual voters so I'm just asking you
to give the voters of New Hampshire a
chance to go in it changes nothing the
absentee structure it's going to be the
exact same way that it's done now the
only difference is they don't put an
excuse in so when the Secretary of
States gets up and says this is going to
lead to massive fraud voter harvesting
all these other horrible things it's no
change the only change is we're not
having them put an excuse so why is it
that harvesting is easier here it's like
saying that when campaigns do rides to
the polls that's horrible because we're
taking a whole group of people and we're
giving them rides to the polls we're
making it easier because we're picking
them up at their houses and driving them
to the polls and campaigns are doing
this and they're sending out forums to
do rides to the polls and they're
picking them up at the same time that
that happened I'm sure back when cars
first came in the Secretary of State
back then thought it was a horrible
thing because we're helping voters and
making it easier well this is what's
happening now and maybe there are
pre-printed forms but they're already
doing pre-int printed forms for people
with the excuses on them so it's just a
step into the future to make more people
vote and yes it's making it easier but
isn't that the point do we want to make
voting really hard for people or do we
want to make it something that people do
it's their civic duty they want to vote
and I think we want people to vote don't
we so I would ask you to please pass
this and I thank you for your
perseverance and listening to all of us
this morning and I represent thank you
representative Rogers if you would you
were me with the question um I think you
were here for part of the public hearing
on HB 61 which was the bill proceeding
yours would you agree that the
provisions as you have proposed in HB
516 are identical to those contained in
HB
61 I can't say for sure because I
haven't read um 61 they sounded like it
um but I would take your opinion for as
as the committee's looked at both bills
I would take your word for it all right
thank you um questions from committee
members in the
room representative
McDonald representative can you okay y
um Deputy scanland mentioned B
harvesting and you addressed that he
also mentioned State constitutional
issues state constitution talks about
the only reasons for absente voting
right now can be
absence or disability have you taken
that into consideration constitutional
issues I know that the committee talked
about this last time and they resolved
that it wasn't there um I think that you
also have the caretaker position um
excuse me caretaker OB section that's in
there's now there's other things in
there and that's not been questioned so
I don't believe it's a
problem thank you other questions
representative Barrett uh yes thank you
uh representative Robert for being here
you said in your customon you referen
the state of Oregon which has near near
Universal absente biding um you said
there's only been 33 cases of voter
fraud in Oregon I'm just curious what is
your acceptable threshold for voter
fraud I mean I think all of us want no
voter fraud but I think that if there's
only been 33 cases in 11 years um and
it's
0.5 that's a pretty low bar so I I think
that we all want none but even our state
has had a little bit of voter fraud over
the course of the last 11
years there's always one person that
tries to do something wrong by intent or
by by um on
education representative Mooney thank
you madam chair thank you representative
Rogers are you able to hear me yes I am
perfect could you direct me if it's
there in your bill as to the time frame
of when uh your bill passed everybody
would be able to vote by absentee ballot
I believe it's upon
passage follow up uh thank you for that
but I'm wondering for example uh okay we
have a primary and then you know a week
before the general or a week before the
primary or a month before these
elections I'm I'm thinking of a time
frame like that oh okay no it would be
the the same as it currently exists in
law this would not change anything about
absentee voting except for the excuse
okay thank you further questions from
committee
members representor o' Brian thank you
mad thank you for being here representa
and explaining your bill you talked
about
it and when you talked about it you
talked about other stat that have
mating I
don't representative Barry said he said
near Universal I think it is universal
in Oregon I'm not aware of any polling
place that a person can go to in org now
do youate this bill with that sort of
situation with mail and voting would you
do you you consider to be a kind of
mailin voting have no
excuse voting
I'm having a hard time hearing you but I
think you asked me if I equated it with
mailin voting is that correct yes no
it's not equated with it but it's
similar in the fact that absentee
ballots are mailed in that's why I
offered the suggestion of an in Oregon
where there is mailin voting and the
situation of fraud but no it's not mail
and voting it's simply the absentees are
done through the mail by and large I
understand some are carried in but by
and large it's done through the
mail thank you
uh are you are you aware of states that
do have more mail in voting uh let's
just say the states that have mail or
states that have no excuse at voting do
they consistently have higher voting
eligible population rates of voting I
think it varies to State um I don't know
all of the statistics I could probably
find them but I know Washington and
Oregon have mail in voting um I don't
know the exact statistic six of their
percent of um
participation thank you further
questions from committee
members I'm not seeing anything oh
representative browan thank you madam
chair uh thank you representative Rogers
for taking my question
um with absentee ballots how can our
election officials verify especially the
more common it becomes the more people
that do it how can they verify that
those who apply for and use the absentee
Val process are actually the persons who
they say they are I think that they
doing the same way they do it now as I
said this changes nothing um it's just
changing the excuse for it um now they
go through and and the moderators look
at the signatures the best they can and
make a decision on that um when they get
them um our law if you want to look at
the verification I think that's a
different part of the statute that you
want to look at this is simply the
excuse part of it um and the exceptions
that we go through with that right now
we have a number of SE exceptions
caretaker sickness um absence from town
disability um you have the same question
there as far as how you verify um I
think that if you want to talk about
verification that's a different part of
the statute that you'd want to get into
and that's something that's um
this committee might want to try to
reform follow up go ahead would you
support uh those who want to do absentee
ballots uh having to go into the clerk
to pick up their abs ballot and show
their voter
ID um no simply because there are some
people that couldn't do that there are
people individually individuals with
disabilities um and I can tell you right
now I am am so I suffer from a
disability and I'm having a flare up
right now I have not been able to get
out of my house for the last three weeks
physically I cannot get out of my house
so if I had to go to the clerk's office
to turn in a ballot I would physically
not be able to do so so I would be um
not allowed to vote and I know there are
other people that are physically unable
to leave their their homes for a reason
of disability um or there there could be
other reasons that they cannot get into
to the clerk's office um so I think that
that would be a problem for people that
would disenfranchise a whole class of
individuals um I think that they're that
trying to figure out how you're going to
verify would be an extremely difficult
thing that you probably want to set up a
whole committee to look at over time and
come up with some suggestions but asking
the clerk asking them to go into a
clerk's office would disenfranchise I
fear a number of people with handicaps
follow thank you madam chair um for
those that you just mentioned are they
not already covered in the current
law yes but you just said would I would
I favor somebody going into the clerk's
office to turn it in to
verify and that would prove a problem
thank you further questions from
committee members for representative
Rogers I'm not seeing any thank you very
much representative Rogers for being
with us this morning thank you madam
chairman and members of the committee
have a good thanks also signed up to
speak on this bill is Janice keville um
Miss keville I see that you're with us
in the waiting room and I have asked the
computer to ask you to join us um if you
unmute welcome to the election law
committee thank you very much good
morning Madam chairman and the committee
members I appreciate the opportunity to
present testimony this morning that I
believe is very important to the people
of New Hampshire my name is Janice Kelby
I'm a retired postal worker and I live
in hookit New Hampshire I can share with
you some firsthand
experiences experiences of some of my
co-workers and of several family members
New Hampshire citizens take their right
and duty to vote very seriously and we
need to keep it that way by expanding
the opportunities to those who have
difficulty being able to cast their vote
during a designated 10 to 12 hour period
on a specific day being first in the
nation gives us a step up in raising
awareness of the importance of voting
now it's time for us to finally update
our laws to make it easier for working
people to have that voice thankfully
voting laws have changed considerably
over the years expanding the rights and
opportunities for people to vote in 1790
white male property owners were the only
voters it took 60 years to pass laws
eliminating property ownership
requirements and to remove religious
prerequisites and a far longer time
before women and African-Americans were
able to participate in our elections
laws across the country have continued
to evolve adapting to changing needs the
static that I'm going to refer to next
are pre pandemic so much changed in our
past election that I don't dare attempt
the national update identifying all of
these very recent and some temporary
changes that were made but in early 2020
there were 39 States plus the District
of Colombia that had some method to
enable eligible voters to participate in
Election Day by casting their Val ballot
prior to election day either during an
open early voting period established by
the state or by requesting an absentee
ballot to more States Virginia and
Delaware enacted early voting to begin
in 2020 and 2022 respectively no excuse
absentee voting is a commonly used
method to allow voters some flexibility
to make casting a ballot possible for
people who might otherwise be denied the
opportunity to
vote three other states Colorado Oregon
and Washington conduct all elections by
mail at that time there were only nine
states offering nothing as an
alternative to voting on Election Day
unfortunately New Hampshire is one of
those few states that has not yet
updated laws to meet the changing needs
of Voters that have occurred over the
years this is not my first time
testifying in favor of no excuse voting
I think it's unrealistic to expect
everybody in today's world to be able to
vote on a Tuesday during the hours that
the polls are open I have experienced
firsthand the difficulty of rising at
the crack of dawn rushing to get my
children up as a single parent dressed
fed and off to school or child care so
that I could get to work on time after
working all day and driving about 25
miles to the daycare center by the time
I got back into my neighborhood assuming
traffic was good I had less than an hour
before the polls closed my children were
ready for dinner lines at the polls were
at their worst and I had two fussy kids
I had to force to wait for their dinner
in order for me to vote the legislature
very wisely recently within the last six
years I'd say um addressed that
particular situation by adding a
dependent care as an acceptable excuse
to request an absentee ballot
unfortunately that was only one of many
cases that needed to be addressed so
while the change was desperately needed
it have failed to address the whole
problem my basic argument for no excuse
absentee voting has has always been the
premise that nothing in life is Promised
for anyone on a given day especially
within restricted hours sadly the 2020
election gave us a very Vivid
illustration of how important that fact
is thankfully through the joint efforts
of many people New Hampshire made it
possible for many who were unsure if
they would be able to appear in person
and voters came out in record numbers to
have their voices heard in a safe secure
election everybody was thrilled with the
outcome
of what was a sudden and unexpected need
right then to develop a system and it
happened honestly to my own amazement I
mean I think we ended up with a very
successful election where a lot of
people's voices were able to be heard I
think this is exactly what we should
always do I think we had 32% of the
electorate was able to vote absentee and
do it safely and
securely nobody should have to worry
about not being able to vote if they get
stuck in traffic after work or if
they're unexpectedly required to work
overtime certainly something I saw
working at the Manchester postal
facility seniors and others who fear
driving in the snow shouldn't have to
choose between driving anyway or not
voting what are their choices if they're
serious about wanting to vote nobody
should have to falsely apply for an
absentee ballot in advance or risk
driving on icy roads if they're not
comfortable doing so just to cast a
ballot voting should not be a game of
chance I wonder how many of you wait
until the last day to file your
paperwork to run for office to become a
state representative I wouldn't wait
till the last till the deadline day some
people surely will and they still be
able to do it if we have no excuse
absentee voting but this is why a window
is needed to allow people to vote uh
nothing is promised to anyone on a given
day and the certainty of being able to
do anything is greatly increased by
offering a window of time and not
restricting it to just one opportunity
unexpected illness car problems family
emergencies bad weather broken water
heater unexpected overtime shouldn't
stop me from having an opportunity to
vote if I truly care I should be able to
make a plan ahead of the deadline just
in case obstacles appear that is
important to me and I hope you agree
this isn't a red state blue State issue
if you look at a map showing voting
rights you'll see that some of the most
Progressive states in the country have
expanded voting opportunities do have
some of the most conservative States
interestingly enough in
1997 Texas of all places passed a bill
allowing residents to cast absentee
ballots from space they did that because
that need existed in their Community it
existed in their state and they changed
the laws to meet the challenges of the
times currently according to our laws a
person votes or attempts to vote by
absentee ballot and does not meet one of
New Hampshire's very restricted limited
acceptable excuses that person shall be
guilty of a misdemeanor planning in
advance in order to ensure a voice in a
local state or national issues should
not be a crime limiting somebody's
ability to participate in our government
is the real crime New Hampshire please
step up to the plate and meet our needs
now let's not be the last state to
listen and to grow I urge you to vote
ought to pass it's the right thing to do
and it's the right time to do it being
known for first in the nation is good
last in the nation not so much thank you
thank you for your testimony this
morning does anybody in the room
question
M anybody attending any committee
members attending electronically have a
question I'm not seeing any thank you
very much for joining us this morning
also signed up to speak on this matter
is open democracy action if you Brian
deal if you could raise your hand that I
thought that was you I wasn't quite
sure um so thank you for joining us this
morning I think if you unmute you should
be all
set on I'm looking for
you
find I'm sorry I hit the wrong button
that's why it's not working you are with
us now I
believe yes you are you unmute we're all
set thank you morning morning good
morning Madam chair and members of the
committee thanks for the opportunity to
speak in favor of HB 516 I am Brian Beal
I'm deputy director of the nonpartisan
Prov voter nonprofit open democracy
action based in conquered and I live in
Alton Bay New Hampshire uh we work on
Democracy issues including the
protection of our inherent American
freedom to vote during the runup to the
2020 general election open democracy our
sister 501c3 sister organization work to
educate voters on the availability of
absentee ballots including making over
200,000 phone calls to lower income
citizens of all parties that's important
all parties and providing instructions
on how to obtain an AB absentee ballot
we did not send mailers out um uh as uh
suggested by uh Deputy scandin uh but we
did on on demand send U absentee ballot
applications out to people who uh
desired them um the people we spoke to
um many of them um elderly or H
homebound were really grateful to learn
that the state of New Hampshire had had
helped to make voting safe and
accessible during the pandemic as you
know the use of absentee ballots for
concern with covid-19 was made possible
last April by the governor's executive
orders and guidance from the New
Hampshire attorney General's office and
Secretary of State New Hampshire
citizens of all parties embraced this
opportunity to vote despite the pandemic
record numbers of Voters were able to
vote
33,105
499 in the general election a fact that
we can all celebrate New Hampshire
citizens um excuse me U included in
those totals were
23,5 190 Republicans who voted by
absentee ballot in the state primary 16%
of all ballots cast Democrats um cast
66411 absentee ballots or 43% in the
general election
26,27 voters of all parties voted by
absentee 32% of the total clearly
Granite Staters appreciated having the
freedom of not having to choose between
their health and their inherent right to
vote so why not make that freedom
permanent why not let New Hampshire
citizens make their own decisions when
it comes to their freedom to vote
instead of having government tell them
whether they're sick enough mobile
enough religious enough or employed
enough to vote by absentee HB 516
removes the current four excuses on the
absentee ballot application and lets the
voter take personal responsibility for
their actions it does not remove the
process of the absentee ballot
application chain of custody or the
processing controls that have served us
well for very me many many years and I
would also add that U Deputy scanland
did not talk about the um the voter
registration process as it relates to uh
absentee ballots and I think it's
important to note that you have to be
registered to be able to vote by
absentee you just don't um uh contact
the State the uh the local town clerk
get a and get a ballot you have to go
through the registration process as well
so that is a check he didn't really
address New Hampshire has allowed
absentee voting uh absentee ballot
voting since um it let Hollis New
Hampshire militia men in
1775 vote by mail during the American
Revolution and from the beginning the
absentee ballot process has been
overseen by our friends and neighbors
who serve as each Town's election
official excuse me officials for 200
years absentee ballots have been until
recently without any suspicion or
accusations or doubt and for that same
time our election officials have
verified those voters and have protected
the Integrity of our elections and they
did so in 2020 with the same commitment
uh to our Republic as they've always had
a record 260,000 absentee ballots were
cast without any significant misuse in
November 2020 and the infantes issues
which did come up are being addressed as
they should be through our checks and
balances because we trust in the
Integrity of our election workers our
checks and balances and the personal
responsibility of our citizens our
system has proven that an absentee
ballot system without excuses can work
for all New Hampshire voters and HB 516
should be voted ought to pass thank you
again for the opportunity to speak Madam
chair and members of the
committee thank you very much Mr V if I
could just follow up myself with one
question you talked about that you need
to be registered before you need to
absentee vote is isn't it true that in
this past election you were able to
register and vote by absentee in the
same
mail you could but you also had to
provide your domicile citizenship uh and
identification documents uh as part of
that registration process all right
thank you questions from committee
members in the
room
question from committee members
attending
online speak up or raise your
hand becoming amb by doing the computer
with my
left I'm not seeing any questions here
speak up thank you very much for coming
and joining us again this morning thank
you kindly I appreciate it Madam chair
also signed up to speak this morning on
this bill is Linda Bundy
um Miss Bundy I have promoted you to
join us on screen if you unmute you are
with us good
morning she was there for one
brief hold on Miss Bundy I I found you
again my vice chair is telling me he
might
have jumped the gun on you if you unmute
you're with us
now thank you good morning Madam chair
and members of the committee my name is
Linda Bundy and I'm a resident of antrum
I'm speaking in support of HB
516 no excuse absentee ballots expand
the ways to participate in the voting
process they allow more people to vote
in the way most convenient for
them people have a variety of reasons
that make it difficult to vote in person
life today is busy with obligations that
consume time and energy residents of
rural communities May lack
transportation to the polls those
without vehicles who live in cities may
not have ready access to public
transportation no excuse absentee
ballots would alleviate these
problems our system of voting in New
Hampshire is safe and secure Secretary
of State Garder and his staff along with
town and City Clerks and poll workers
take pride and work hard to ensure that
elections in New Hampshire are fair and
free they follow best practices and
manage elections with integrity and
honesty instances of fraud are extremely
rare absentee ballots are carefully
checked and tracked throughout the
process no excuse absentee ballots make
it easier for a person to vote
regardless of his or her
circumstances this is a way to improve
our election system and increase voter
turnout while maintaining a safe secure
and accessible electoral process I urge
you to support this bill and vote ought
to pass thank you for your
time thank you for joining us miss Bundy
does anybody have any questions from
Miss Bund in the room here today
anybody have questions from the
committee that are attending
electronically I'm not seeing any so
thank you very much for joining us also
signed up to speak on this bill this
this morning is Mr Hatcher Mr Hatcher I
believe that I have asked you to join
the meeting and if you unmute yourself
we look forward to hearing your
testimony good morning thank you madam
chair I'm testifying today in support of
HB
516 in January Secretary of State
William Gardner delivered a presentation
on the 2020 election to your committee I
was struck that secretary Gardner did
not mention fraud once the topic only
came up when committee members asked
Deputy scanland for help debunking
claims from constituents about the
possible influence of dominion voting
machines on the New Hampshire
elections yet now the debate on many of
the bills being considered in this
committee is centered on claims for
actual or potential fraud one such bill
is HB 516 calling for no excuse absentee
balloting the November election a record
number of Voters used absentee ballots
nearly one-third of the total votes cast
while 45% of the absentee ballots were
cast by democrats 55% were cast by
Republicans and Undeclared voters this
broad use of abente voting helped to
generate record turnout even in the
midst of a pandemic and even with record
turnout no evidence of widespread fraud
has emerged including with absentee
ballot we should be celebrating this
accomplishment this High rate of
participation in our democracy and we
should allow no excuse absentee
balloting to enable the success to be
continued into future elections please
vote off to pass for HB
516 thank you very much thank you Mr
Hatcher for joining us this morning and
testifying is there anybody here who has
any questions for Mr Hatcher who
speaking inor
Bill are there any committe members
attending electronically who questions
for
Mr I'm not seeing any thank
you have a number of people in
attendance is there anybody else who
would like to provide testimony for
House Bill
516 relating to no excuse AB vality if
you raise your hand you will be happy to
hear from you here this
[Music]
morning um I don't see Mr Barn here he
has signed up for a couple bills this
morning and I haven't seen him and when
I'm asking for some and I've got a
couple people raising their hands
representative Cody I just wanted to ask
you to please read those signed in in
favor and opposed to this thank you
madam chair um thank you representative
Cody I am going to decline that request
this is not like the blue sheets of old
I have um multiple pages of people
signed in the sign in are in support
there's probably over 20 is people per
page and I have six pages and I believe
each Committee Member is getting emailed
the sign and sheets on the morning of
the
testimony thank you madam
chair my voice would get very monotonous
to everyone if I kept reading this
um I'm just ask I was just asking for
numbers Madam chair but that's okay all
right yeah I mean I don't they're not
number they're just listed on the page
um I see that a Miss cotton
has raised their hand and I haven't
actually closed the public hearing so do
cotton if you unmute I think you can
join us
thank you good morning um I did not
anticipate requesting to speak today but
after after listening very carefully um
I just wanted to add an aspect to the
testimony with regards to no excuse uh
absentee voting uh I I I thank you very
much uh you and and the committee
members for giving me this
opportunity I uh
support uh hosp 56 Ste I am an
immunosuppressed person um I have had
extensive and very rigorous uh cancer
treatment and fortunately I am cancer
free however the residual effects from
that treatment renders me
immunosuppressed and renders me very
susceptible to illness now the covid um
Provisions have certainly helped with
that but there are also other things
that persist year-over-year such as our
fall and Spring Town elections are
during flu season and that's a season
where I need to avoid uh a lot of
contact with the outside similarly to
what we're doing right now for covid
concerns I know there are
folks undergoing uh active uh
chemotherapies I know there are folks
out there who have other
immunosuppressed dis disorders
comorbidities Transportation issues we
face you know our fall and spring
elections potentially during bad weather
seasons and folks um have transportation
issues there's sometimes an issue of
access for some of our more remote
locations folks are relying on other
people to get them here and there to
polling places and
those arrangements are not always
consistent so there are a lot of lenses
that I would just like you to look
through when you're considering
legislation such as this we had a very
uh robust voter turnout which I think is
just a salute to our Democratic process
I think that it allowed um many people
to vote that otherwise would not have
done that but even after after hopefully
soon Co is a thing in our history and in
our past there are other consistent uh
conditions that prevent us from wanting
to expose ourselves to large numbers of
public um or to have the opportunity to
even get there so uh we are not
considered disabled we are not
considered infirmed so we don't
currently fit into any of the current
slots that uh allow us to have the
option of voting absentee so I would
just like you to consider that a little
broadly and also uh would like you to
consider a to pass on this very
important measure and I thank you so
much for uh allowing uh this Caboose to
uh join the end of the train here and uh
give you some of my words this
morning thank you for joining us does
any anybody have any questions from this
spot do any of the members attending
online have a question from
spot I'm not seeing
any so I still have a number of people
online I don't have anybody else with
their handre for testimony on HB
516 our next public hearing this morning
is on
hb14 relative to the absente request
form that is scheduled to start at 11
115 so we are in recess until
11:15 thank you and good morning
representative
B sorry good morning all right 10
minutes see
you
I
[Music]
she
I thought he
saw something he posted
on
right
for
we are unmuted this is the house
election law committee it is 11:15 we
have a hearing on House Bill 144 House
Bill 144 is relative to absentee ballot
requests and the prime sponsor is a
member of our committee who has joined
us this morning so representative B
welcome to introduce your thank you
madam
chairman shall I begin please do thank
you I emailed a uh a copy of the bullets
that I'll be talking about during my
testimony to members of the committee
last night hopefully you receive that
and even if you didn't have a chance to
look at it hopefully you have it before
you attached to that those bullets are a
copy of an amendment I'm going to be
proposing uh the amendment is very
lengthy but it's actually very simple so
I I will explain what that does in my um
remarks I also sent along a copy of the
current absentee ballot request form
that's available on the Secretary of
State's website because again you know
we're we're kind of talking a little bit
about form design and I thought it might
be helpful for you to be able to look at
the actual form that that we're talking
about um some of these Provisions were
in House Bill 1266 which uh uh when it
was sent over to which I sponsored last
term which was sent over to the Senate
and became the vehicle for the absentee
ballot request forms for uh covid and so
some of the elements of the bill that
were originally contained in that bill
um were not acted upon and some of the
other uh Provisions being uh proposed
here were the result of discussions held
during executive sessions for the
committee during the last term so let me
begin
uh the first thing that the bill
proposes is breaking out the language
that pertains to the request for an
absentee ballot for the presidential
primary election from that for all other
elections oh
no and uh the uh reason for doing that
was sometimes there's an overlap when
the presidential election comes along
and during discussion in executive
sessions some of the committee members
felt it would be nice not to have all
that language pertaining to the
presidential primary election included
in an absentee ballot request form that
might be used for a city election or or
a u another special election being held
in the fall um there there is no changes
any changes being made to the main
absentee ballot request form are
reflected in in the presidential primary
absentee ballot request form and that
includes basically all the section
dealing beginning on page three line 32
through page five line 19
uh the second change that's occurring
and that's what the amendment is is
about appreciated the heads up I cop
that you could always write him back
representative W can you mute sorry all
right thank you I'm sorry for getting
distracted
um currently the proposed bill says one
of the reasons for requesting an absente
ballot is because I am unable to vote in
person due to a disability confinement
observance of a religious commitment or
and it continues and so the proposed
amendment would change confinement to
the words uh incarceration for reasons
other than a felony conviction so that
we make it clear to the person filling
out the form that if they're confined
for a felony they're not eligible to
request for an absentee ballot and so
that's uh the purpose of the amendment
that I was submitting as well uh bullet
number three this deals with uh
uh the text on the absentee ballot
request form in section
one the text for the second checkoff box
is kind of convoluted if you were to
look at the form it says I here hereby
declare that one I am a duly qualified
voter who is currently registered to
vote in this town award and the second
check off box is I am absent from the
town city where I am domiciled and so
what I would find as city clerk is a lot
of people would automatically just check
off the first box and then the second
one because they're asking for the
absentee ballot because they're absent
uh but that second check off box really
is intended for people who um are not
registered to vote and wish to vote
absentee so the language of that is
proposed to be changed to I am unable to
register to vote in person because I am
absent from the city Town Place or Ward
where I I'm domiciled and will be until
the next election and and request that
the forms necessary for absentee voter
registration be sent me with me with the
absentee ballot um the language change
really is just for clarification
purposes for the voter and it C it
reduces confusion when the city clerks
and town clerks receive the forms back
to
them um I would also note that I
proposed adding the word ward to uh the
cluster of words that say I am absent
from the city Town unincorporated place
or Ward where I am domiciled uh in the
large cities sometimes it's just as hard
to get from one end of the city to the
other as it is to get perhaps from
Hudson to Lichfield and so since it's a
separate District voting district uh the
request there is to add the word
ward um the fourth
bullet uh the current absentee ballot
request form provides six check off
boxes for reasons why an absentee ballot
may be requested Ed and House Bill 555
is providing a seventh uh reason the U
Bill proposes that some of these similar
uh reasons for requesting an absentee
ballot be clustered together so that now
there will only be three check off boxes
for the person to choose
from um page two lines 13 to 24 that's
really just a
textual uh grammar change if you will to
make the phras is State primary election
and state general election parallel and
the current law one says State primary
the other one says general election now
they would both say State primary
election or state general election the
other change being made is that the
passage dealing with uh for primary
elections I am a member of or I am now
declaring my affiliation with the
following Republican or Democratic party
that language is placed underneath the
check off box for State primary election
instead of appearing under the check off
box for state general election uh again
it's just trying to make the form a
little easier to understand for the
voter
um the next change which would be my
bullet uh
six if you look at the bottom of the
current absentee ballot request form it
says you at the bottom turnover you must
complete the back side and when you go
to the second side side of the um
absentee ballot request form that
includes information asking for the
applicants email address and the
applicant signature certainly that's
helpful information for the city and
town clerks to contact voters if they
have any problems with the absentee
ballot application uh but technically
it's not a requirement to obtain the
absentee ballot request form so my
proposal is simply to move that those
two c s underneath the voter signature
and make it clear by adding the word
optional that the voter doesn't have to
fill that out uh in order to obtain an
absentee ballot uh request form and I
think it's also more consistent with the
recent uh change to our state
constitution where voters approved uh a
provision that uh really wants the state
to minimize the kind of personal
information it's collecting and storing
um on the citizens behalf
um number
seven and this pertains to
um let's see where click
that representative Veron when did you
send that email with the amendment I'm
not finding it in my email uh last night
um it might have
been I'll keep
looking okay thanks
the
um all right I apologize I can't find it
quickly either
um the next section section seven talks
about changing the absentee envelope
affidavit if you've seen that affidavit
it's very small type and it has two
boxes on it where the individual has to
make a decision as to whether or not
they're going to sign under the section
deals absence from city or town or sign
in the section that says absence because
of religious observance of or physical
disability uh the bill proposes that
there only be one box one signoff box
essentially the two are combined and the
voter simply signs the affidavit
envelope um really none of this
information is tracked uh if you have a
single box and it's combined language
presumably the font can be bigger and it
would be easier for their voters to read
it and also realize that they need to
sign the affidavit
envelope and then the final change
that's being proposed for the absentee
ballots appears on page 7 section 3
Lines
26-34 um the amendment removes the text
quote the signatures on the affidavit
shall be examined to determine if it
appears to be executed executed by the
same person who signed the application
and in its place language is inserted
that states the signature on the
affidavit shall be by the same person
who signed the application
this amendment is intended to ensure
that a voter's ballot is not rejected
due due to a signature mismatch and U
that reflects the uh the intent and and
the order in the Mary Soo versus William
Gardner uh Secretary of State U order um
on pages 43 to
45 so it's it's it's rather detailed um
I apologize if the Committees didn't see
or receive the uh
my summary of it it is kind of
overwhelming considered considering the
amount of material that we do receive uh
but if the committee has any questions I
would be happy to uh to respond thank
you representative Bon representative
Wells had the email I just can't find it
online so I have forwarded it to myself
I want to thank you for your explanation
because there were a couple of changes
you made and I wasn't really quite sure
what you were trying to do so you
certainly answered some questions for me
going through the bill uh questions for
representative perser on on this bill
members of the committee in the
room members of the committee attending
electronically I think you sort done so
much
questions I'm not seeing any questions
from
anybody representative home o'ri just
trying to to
it than I'm already answer
apologizes
yes 12 it says or I am unable to
register vote to vote in person because
um does this expand
any right that is
not
available no um and in fact that was the
one of the purposes of house build 1266
which the uh election law committee I
believe we passed it unanimously and
sent it over to the Senate if you were
to look at the actual absentee ballot
request form that currently exists that
sentence is pretty convoluted it's it
appears in section one of the absentee
ballot form and it currently reads I am
absent from the town city where I am
domiciled and will be until the next
election or I am unable to register in
person due to a disability and request
that the forms necessary for absentee
voter registration be sent to me with
the absentee ballot so the purpose of
that check off box is that your the
voter is ask the resident is asking for
absentee voter registration information
to be sent to them but it appears at at
the end of a three-line sentence so the
voter doesn't really understand what
that is all about until they get to the
end of the sentence so all I'm doing is
suggesting you take the back end of
what's currently on the form and put it
to the front of the phrase so right away
the person who's reading it says I am
unable to register to vote in person
because that's what that check off box
is for so we're not changing the intent
at all we're just kind of restructuring
the sentence so that the purpose of that
sentence appears at the beginning rather
than the
end that's the college composition
teacher coming through I'm sorry for
that representative Moody thank you very
much Madam chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
and thank you for your time and effort
on this sometimes the application and
the envelope you have to read almost a
few times to really be sure you're
checking what you're supposed to be
checking so it's nice that you put the
thought and time into it
when it comes to page
seven you have new language there
talking about uh variation in the
voter's
signatures uh and then further down it
says that the moderator shall not reject
an absentee ballot due to a variation
can you explain how that's different
from current
practice yes it it it goes and and you
know this can change because the the
legislature has the right to change the
laws of course um but this comes from
the 2018 decision from uh uh US District
Court Mary Solo versus William Gardner
Secretary of State uh and that's
essentially where the Court ruled that
um election officials moderators are not
handwriting experts and they shouldn't
um reject an absentee ballot a uh
at an absentee ballot because the
signatures do not appear to be um
exactly the same or or strongly s
similar uh between what appears on the
affidavit envelope and the request form
it was a a similar case although it
dealt with petitions in uh nashwa in
1998 where the Court's order from
Justice delanis actually um said that
there are dangers to attempting to
compare signatures in the ab absence of
handwriting expertise so all this is
saying is yeah the voter needs to sign
the affidavit we have to have that but
the moderator uh is is not to make a
judgment on whether or not that
signature is the exactly the same as the
signature that appears on the absentee
ballot request form so that was
addressed when uh the legislature
repealed section I think it was 650
Roman numeral 3 uh which was ordered by
the court but this piece of language
which appeared in 659 52 uh wasn't
amended further question I do actually
uh any chance you have a citation on
that case or sure the uh US District
Court is uh uh civil number
17-
cv-1 183
dlm and it was opinion number
2018 DNH
160 representative berson do you have
the spelling of the plaintiff's last
name because I think that people will
just be able to Google and the case sure
that's uh Mary Soo and I may be
mispronouncing it it's uh s Au Ce
do thank you thanks and the the related
case although again it deals with
petitions but it does deal with
handwriting signatures was uh uh 98-
E350 Civic nashille Civic form versus
elanar Benson as city clerk of
nashille any other questions for
representative
berson representative quy thank you
madam chairman repres Senor B thank you
for taking my question I have a question
relates that relates to I'll call it the
weather excuse bottom of page one
starting with line 30 yes it currently
says that this this option is available
only Monday immediately prior to the
election we cross that out but
also it states cannot appear by pulling
place an election day because of
National Weather Service storm warning
Etc but there are two addition
conditions uh you need one of which you
need to check off one about being elbow
or firm or physical disability and
worried about your safety the other
being that school Child Care adult care
will be cancelled so what it appears is
happening with this uh change if I
understand it right is that you're
changing an excuse that depends on the
weather in some other condition that you
experience to Simply an excuse for the
weather having been forecast to be B do
I understand that understanding that
correctly
yes okay thank
you anybody else who has a question for
representative
HB anybody else I'm not seeing anybody
thank you representative all right thank
you very
much kennes has signed up to speak on
this also he not do not see as an
attend Deputy scanland stand upy
scanland
welcome thank you madam chair members of
the committee I'm David scanland deputy
secretary of state uh I would like to
just recognize I think represent berson
did a great job trying to clarify some
of this uh uh confusing language on the
on the application form and the
affidavit um and so the the comment that
I would like to make is not unique to
represent berson's bill but just in
general over the last few bium we have
been adding language to uh both the
application and the affidavit I think I
think in this case representative Bon
may have cleaned some of that up but
just uh for an example I'm going to put
up this is the affid
envelope um and you can see that the
whole envelope is covered in text uh and
signature lines and so at some point uh
you know I would like to participate in
an exercise uh with your committee where
we might try and somehow condense the
language that goes on uh both the
application and the affidavit so that
that is simpler and more easily read uh
by the voter and the election officials
uh maybe it means an accompanying form
that defines some of the things that the
uh that the voter is going to sign when
they acknowledge the affidavit um I just
point that out because you know with
there may be some other bills out there
dealing with this language as well and
at some point we're just going to have
to address the physical space that's
required on the fors and the envelope
I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank
you
anybody have any questions
for representative Cody do you have a
question yes ma'am um I just wanted to
ask since since you did mention that
representative burgon had done such a
good job cleaning up some of the
language I I wanted to know whether that
meant you all were in favor of the bill
or
not I we we generally support the bill
yes thank
you
any further questions from committee
members SC I'm not seeing any thank you
Deputy scalan is there anybody else in
attendance for this hearing on HB 144
who would like to
speak please raise your hand and I'll be
happy to recognize
you I'm not seeing
anybody um so I'm going to close the the
hearing on HB
144 at this time just committee for
purposes of scheduling you receive the
house calendar um I just want to review
what's going on over the next couple of
days I do have to leave for an
appointment probably before the last
hearing finishes today uh Vice chairman
McDonald will be taking over we have a
meeting tomorrow we have public Hearing
in the morning we have executive session
in the
afternoon if you look at your calendar
for Monday we have public hearing on the
remaining bills an executive session
starting in the
afternoon um we have the zoom license
and the space for Monday and Wednesday
next week um those were taken in EMP
Poli with getting the bills out for
deadlines um in finishing our work in an
adequate time to get things done with
committee reports done for the calendar
um if we are at a point on Monday where
it looks like we might be able to exact
all bills it would be the chair's
preference to continue not to 8 o' at
night um but to not quit at 3 o' if it
looks like we can get through everything
that of course will depend on our
executive session on bills we do have
Wednesday but I just wanted to let
everybody know so you can sort of digest
it and see how you feel um um that if it
is possible I would like to get through
the bills on Monday afternoon we will
only exact the bills
tomorrow um that are on the schedule
unless there's an agreement to EXA
anything else between uh representative
Cod and myself so I just wanted to let
everybody know that's what's going on
with the scheduling so you can plan
accordingly and we are now I think in
break for lunch and we will will'll be
back at 1:00 for a hearing on 292 which
is in regards to the absentee valid
application process thank you everybody
and have a good
lunch
speak of you uh I believe I said speak
no I
not here you go all
right we uned
M
on
hold on everybody like the chair has to
set an alarm because she's not capable
of remembering she
has
good afternoon everybody this is the
house election law
committee uh we are reconvened after
lunch it is Thursday March 4th it is one
o'clock by my computer 103 by 1 o' and
12:59 by another o'clock so we're going
with my one o' uh the public hearing
that we have is on 292 House Bill 292
this is relative to the absentee ballot
application process uh with us here to
speak and present on the bill is
representative Hill the prime sponsor
welcome representative Hill thank you
madam chair um for the record my name is
representative Greg Hill I represent the
town of Northfield and onethird of the
city of
Franklin um with your permission I'll
read my testimony because that will save
us time um much better to run through it
that way rather than hums and Oz thank
you um in in college my nickname was uh
Harry Snodgrass for a while um Harry is
a real life person although we've never
met um as St starving college students
my group of friends learned that a
neighboring College catered Buffet
corporate lunches and we learned how to
casually walk by the signin desk and
surreptitiously glance at remaining name
tags
we would then pick a name from the
remaining name tags and return a few
minutes and announce
ourselves uh and be given the name tag
and consequently receive our goal of
free all you can eat cater
food um the last time we worked this
scam Harry Snodgrass was the only
remaining male name and so I became
Harry
Snodgrass um I believe we have a similar
scam possible in New Hampshire elections
with mail in absentee ballots
and lots of Harry snod grasses that is
people who didn't show up to vote
specifically I will be discussing mailin
absentee ballot requests and even more
specifically those requests asking that
their ballot be mailed to an address
other than the verified address shown in
the
checklist there are three key points to
this
discussion one mailed in absentee ballot
requests are the only only method of
voting in New Hampshire that doesn't
require any positive
identification to be clear in New
Hampshire currently if I know Harry
Snodgrass exists on a voter checklist I
can simply declare myself to be Harry
Snodgrass and request to have a Harry
Snodgrass absentee ballot mailed to me
at any address inside the United States
and raise not a single eyebrow or red
flag a clerk may even know Harry but he
or she doesn't have a single ability to
question whether I am Harry Snodgrass or
not two it is remarkably easy to create
lists of names of Harry snodgres in New
Hampshire that is those who most
probably will not show up at the polls
and claim their own vote I know of three
possible ways to build a checklist of
thousands of possible Harry snod grasses
but I'm sure there are more ways than
the ones I thought
of if they do show up at the polls more
likely than not the checkin people will
assume it was a mistake and they make up
a new name tag for
Harry three almost no person I've ever
met who has chosen not to vote will ever
take the time to do the research with
their own town clerk to see if anyone
claiming to be Harry
Snodgrass themselves took their B and
voted in their name by
absentee as a side note even if they did
it's written off as an error of some
kind and never investigated so this is a
crime that goes undetected or
unexamined Harry snod grass's ballot
Gets In The Ballot Box and Harry
probably never knows it this is a very
bad situation in New Hampshire imagine
for a second if we had some a situation
where someone anyone could walk in into
TD Bank and claim to be Harry Snodgrass
and asked for all the money in Harry
Snodgrass his bank account or
Worse what is what is more valuable than
a person's vote but it's worse if
somebody could mail in a letter saying
in the mail just mail me the money in
account number 1234 I am Harry snod
can't shouldn't be
done this bill protects both Harry and
Harry's vote
um it requires a copy of Harry's ID or
notorized signature to obtain Harry's
ballot under those specific conditions
or assigned challenged at voter
affidavit and this this only applies
when the ballot is requested by mail and
when the ballot is mailed to an address
other than the addressing record on the
checklist there is an amendment that was
sent to the committee uh this morning at
8:49 a.m. by
s um they actually contacted me and said
that the um original drafting did not
include all of the options that I had
originally requested so the amendment uh
the current bill as it shows um uh an A
and A B for the voter voluntarily shows
a clerk a photo ID meets the
requirements of RSA
659 and B the voter voluntarily includes
a notorized signature on his or her
completed absentee ballot form the
corrected version is the voter
voluntarily includes with the returned
absentee ballot to the clerk a copy of
their photo identification that meets
the requirements of RSA 1
659 B the voter voluntarily completes a
challenge voter affidavit in the same
manner as required for an election day
voter who who does not present a
qualified voter identification or C the
voter voluntarily includes a notorized
signature on his or her completed
absolute absentee ballot application
form and that's the only difference from
in in the amendment it it gives another
option it gives that uh that option of
the challenge voter affidavit and it
also U changes from the giving the clerk
a photo identification to the photo
identification is a copy that is sent in
with their with their absente valot with
that I'll close my testimony I'm happy
to answer any questions that the
committee has um I'm not sure the
procedure of getting this
amendment to you all I assume it's
already there I just have not figured
out that system yet I I just before we
take questions um I just looked I did
not find it but I'm not finding things
in my email this is the second on today
um so I'm going to assume it has it
and I told someone this for a hearing
tomorrow executive session if you want
the amendment consider find somebody on
the to introduce it and it will be
considered anybody have questions for
representative Hill here in the
committee
room questions for attendees
online speak up I don't see any hands
but if somebody's got something
not I'm not see any questions so thank
you
very bills thank 292 relative to
absentee valid
application I also have Bob Perry signed
us to speak I do not see him signed on
at this time Ken Barnes has signed
up
oh I'm sorry Mr Perry there you are yes
let's yeah sorry
I if you unmute Mr Perry you were with
us thank you very much Madam chair I'm
glad I was uh
discovered uh Madam chair and members of
the
committee I do not know the level of
occurrence during an election cycle that
an absentee ballot applicant requests
his or her ballot be returned to an
address inconsistent with that shown on
the absentee ballot application form a
number likely known to the prime
sponsor no matter I speak to
the here we go
sorry I speak to the worth of signature
comparison
aside from the Natural Evolution of a
person's handwriting with age and
specifically the changes in a person's
signature with age and with me the level
of caffeine in my system I have come to
understand that there are many other
valid reasons that signature comparison
is perilous at
best the national Multiple Sclerosis
Society reported two years ago that
quote around 900,000 Americans and quite
Poss possibly more than that have
multiple
sclerosis easily double the long
accepted figure of 400,000 end quote the
reference in the quote to quite possibly
more means it is possible many more
Americans have the disease don't know it
and among them
voters women make up 74% of Ms patients
linked to a vitamin D deficiency the
farther away from the equator the higher
the incidence of the disease quote
people living in the nine US states
comprising the Northeast end quot
including New Hampshire and end quote
begin quote have a high prevalence of
377 per 100,000 inhabitants end quote
thus there could be as many as
4,524 New Hampshire inhabitants among
them voters whose handwriting could be
affected dayto Day based on severity of
the disease medication levels and other
variables Ms quote Ms includes loss of
hand dexterity and finger movement
control this affects a patient's
capacity to manipulate objects and
coordinate hand movement skills needed
in handwriting end
quote I search for the phrase quote
diseases that affect handwriting end
quote results Huntington disease as many
as 200,000 in the United States hinson's
disease and estimated 3600 in New
Hampshire a condition known as disg
graphia the onset of Al Alzheimer's an
estimated 26,000 cases ages 65 to 85
Plus in New Hampshire multiple
handwriting Styles in one
person and
schizophrenia even professional
handwriting experts disagree in
analyzing the same signature as in a
court setting indeed judges in both
criminal and cival cases instruct the
jury that they may choose to accept the
testimony of one expert over the other
or choose to accept the testimony of
neither I suggest obligating election
Personnel to compare a person's
signature is beyond difficult likely an
unwanted responsibility on their part
and if the result is the loss of an
otherwise legit imate person's
fundamental right to vote grounds for
legal
redress I urge TL and Madam chair I I
would like leave to read the testimony
of a friend who was unable to navigate
uh the website um we're both over 12 so
it's difficult for both of
us being kind to many of us Mr
Perry all right I'll I'll allow you to
I've got other people here signed up to
speak but why don't you read the
person's name into the record and go
ahead thank you very much
ma'am to house election law Kitty uh
committee thank you for the opportunity
to provide written testimony on House
Bill 292 which establishes procedures
relative to the absentee ballot
application process including signature
comparison I oppose passage of this bill
because the provision that requires the
comparison of the voters signat would
provide an undue burden on people with
certain disabilities such as multiple
sclerosis I have MS and have lived with
it for decades however it took many
years dealing with a range of
frustrating episodic
symptoms before I got a definitive
diagnosis around a year before a neur a
urologist told me I had Ms I found
myself in Las Vegas on a business trip
on my last day there I was not feeling
well and decided to rest in the Sun by
the swimming pool before I packed and
checked out of the hotel not a good idea
because heat exacerbates MS symptoms
after 30 minutes in the heat my hands
and lower limbs became tingly and stiff
and my gate became unsteady and I had no
idea why when I went to check out I
presented my credit card and signed the
statement the employee behind the desk
refused to accept my cad and said the
signatures did not
match I asked to speak to the manager
and was told by management that they had
to be careful for fraudulent cards in a
city like Las Vegas I was already
feeling ill and the rejection of my card
only added to my stress I had to find a
co-worker and then my supervisor to
vouch for me before I could get my card
back complete the transaction and get to
the airport in time for my return flight
I wanted to share this story with the
committee because it illustrates how
certain illnesses can impair one's hand
dexterity and change one's
signature there are many people who have
MS and do not know it and some never get
a
diagnosis by the way in my case I
experienced symptoms in my extremities
with each exacerbation including on one
occasion loss of use of my right hand
hand for a period of weeks I urge the
committee to take my story into
consideration in your deliberations and
vote
itl and I thank members thank you Mr
Perry who's who wrote that what was the
name of that person yes it's uh Joan
Jacobs and in the um document that I
submitted last night being her
presentation she provides her contact
information all right thank you I just
didn't hear it when you reading does
anybody have any questions for Mr Perry
anybody attending online have any
questions for Mr
per I'm
not representative Brian thank you madam
chair lost here and i' like some
clarification perhaps from the author
Bill about current law
versus what section two and what section
ask for
then clarify
some uh representative I are you
referring to a and b in the
bill uh section two starting on line 12
section three
stud 16 I would just like that clarified
and also how it compares to current law
so yes I'm I'm asking the the author of
the bill here in the room us
so I'm just a
little lost here you're talking
about verification just like
clarification about current
law if you can answer Mr Perry yes I I'm
I'm actually having trouble hearing but
my understanding is that signature
comparison um is at least temporarily on
hold
uh and to be honest I don't know whether
that is a ruling uh within the state
court or the federal
courts um but uh obviously in some
states there are requirements for
Signature match and I I think it's
uh very troubling place to be okay thank
you you only have to answer what you're
sure you know Mr Perry don't worry about
it thank you um representative toosan
thank you madam chair thank you Mr Perry
for taking my question
in regard to theory of people you
described um would not a
solution to that um signature
verification B if they would comply with
um part A and B of this proposed
legislation are you familiar with what
those say I'd be glad to read them if
you're not no I have that in front of me
representative and yes it surely would
but those um reliefs are not available
to
everyone um
so those would be in my opinion
impediments any other questions from
committee members in the room or online
representative brow thank you madam
chair and thank you uh Mr Perry for
taking my question um if we don't use
the verification items in A and B and if
we don't use signature
you have thoughts on how we can assure
that the applicant for a an absentee
ballot is truly the person that he or
she says they
are well there are several options
including same day registration uh the
qualified voter
affidavit um and I think U most voters
know that um the Attorney General's
office is ready to investigate um
anything that that Max of
fraud further questions from committee
members in the room representative to ro
Madam chair thank you again Mr Perry for
taking my question I'm just curious um
you mentioned that solution may be same
day voter registration could you please
elaborate on how that would alleviate
the
problem um through the simple process of
um registering and voting on voting day
same day
registration um people come in they can
vote if they sign an affidavit that says
they are who they say they
are further questions from committee
members attending iners or
online I'm not seeing
any thank you Mr carry for joining us
this afternoon nice to see you thank you
ma'am
likewise um also signed up to speak on
this bill is Michael O'Brien from
America vots welcome Mr O'Brien to the
election La committee if you unmute you
should be set to
go thank you madam chair uh members of
the committee uh my name is Michael
O'Brien I'm here uh with I'm with party
strategies and my client I'm
representing is America votes I'm here
today in opposition to House Bill 292 um
I just want to talk about a little bit
some the voters that we're probably
talking about this lot impacting so uh
for those folks who don't fully
understand so there's a group a really
sort of three groups that pop into my
head of Voters who will request a ballot
um from a domiciled address uh their
voter domicile being different from
their request the ballot uh certainly
snowbirds folks who live um in uh
Florida or Arizona or somewhere else for
a portion of the Year may fall into that
category uh a student who lives grew up
in New Hampshire and goes to college in
a different state would fall into that
category and then lastly and I think the
one that we should be most careful about
as we we talk about this bill is folks
who live in nursing homes um who still
have the ability to vote at their
previous domicile um but live in the
nursing home so for that voter in
particular what we're now asking and I
don't have the amendment in front of me
and so um it's obviously a little
different than the bill um but what we
are now asking is that they uh do one of
these things that is after mentioned
we're asking someone who lives in a
nursing home to uh show up at their town
hall or we're asking them to get a
notorized signature um and if not we're
asking them to Signature mismatch which
as we learned this morning as uh Mr
Perry alluded to in the previous
testimony um is currently illegal in the
state of New Hampshire um so now what
you're saying since we know part three
of this bill doesn't work um or isn't is
illegal at the moment um that you're
leaving two voluntary measures um
left on the book so so a law without
enforcement effectively um is what you
would be passing into law I do worry um
I know it's been mentioned a lot this
morning that there is no uh mandated
verification uh for someone who drops
off an absente ballot uh into town hall
I know a lot of town clerks who do a
request and ask for their photo ID even
though it's just voluntary within the
law um and I worry that making voluntary
quote unquote voluntary laws uh will
become mandates uh based on the local
level which can cause certainly
confusion um throughout the state so uh
we're opposed to this bill uh for a
variety of reasons I will say on a
personal note um my father uh has Ms he
was diagnosed with multiple sceris in
1978 he's lived with it now um he blames
Bucky Dent hitting that home run uh for
the reason he got Ms in the first place
um and he's lived with it for you know
40 years um and Ms affects his
day-to-day life uh in ways that I've
certainly seen growing up um and but are
unimaginable to me without seeing a
day-to-day and um certainly that
provision that part um inspires a lot of
nervousness within me because of that
and knowing that I'm happy to take any
questions from the members of the
committee thank you Mr O'Brien anybody
have any questions for Mr O'Brien here
in the committee
room any committee members attending
online have a question for
mrri
I'm not seeing any so thank you very
much for joining us this afternoon also
signed up to speak on this bill
is I think my chair has moved you up is
Janice
K are you with
us no it's Janice Kelby and I promise to
be shorter this time thank you
for okay um
I want to speak in opposition to House
Bill
292 again my name is Janice Kelby and I
live in hooks at New Hampshire it's my
understanding that voters can vote from
an address where they live before
entering a nursing home my husband and I
lived in a home that we bought in
Franklin New Hampshire and we lived
there for nearly 20 years when he was
finally forced to receive care in a
nursing home outside of Franklin for a
couple of years I can speak of
experiences at both of those
places um that my husband who suffered
from Parkinson's and he spent time in
two different nursing homes both of them
were not in Franklin in the first home
he was in it was probably no that anyone
would have made any effort to assist him
with needs of having somebody come in to
notarize a ballot we were frankly pretty
lucky when they had sufficient staff to
take care of his basic medical needs in
the second home I'm fairly confident
they would likely have made a great
effort to make the arrangements for a
notary to be available to assist him
based on Staffing ability communication
and the time frame they would have to
allow him to have it done in a timely
manner to have him safely return his
ballot it may or may not happen but him
being able to have a voice shouldn't be
dependent on another person if he was if
they were not able to meet that time
constraint and his needs it would have
placed a burden on him that would have
resulted in him losing his right to vote
which was always important to him and
was always a source of Pride to him
sadly his condition in Mobility had
worsened to the point that I could no
longer take him out of the nursing home
on my own to go get a signature
notorized the last attempt I made to
take him out of the nursing home was to
a Parkinson support group that he loved
and it took three people to safely get
him out of my car and into a wheelchair
fortunately there were medical people
there to assist me but without that help
I don't know what I would have done so
it's not something we can take for
granted that something that may be easy
for you or I to do might not be so easy
for somebody else to do I think it puts
an undue burden on people who are often
the least able to afford that bur I'd
like to add a very real story that is
the story of my attempts to get
signatures which I understand right now
that's not legal anyway but if it were
it's not a very good test Parkinson's is
a progressive disease my husband had it
for 27 years before he died last year
but um getting his signature on legal
documents where I needed it was a true
test in patience and trying to allow my
husband to retain any bit of his dignity
and I can honestly tell you that when a
Parkinson's person some takes medication
they have periods when they're off and
they have periods that were on I could
get I sometimes got his signature five
or six times in a day trying to get one
I'd make five copies of something and
hope that one of them would reasonably
like the signature of the man that I
married so that whoever I needed it for
for a legal document would think that it
wasn't something that I chicken
scratched honestly I could have signed
his name to look like his voter
registration name a lot easier than he
could you would never have matched the
two signatures in fact I doubt if you
would have matched a signature from him
at 10:00 a.m with a signature for him at
3 pm so I just think that these are
unfair burdens to place on somebody who
can least afford additional burdens in
their life thank
you thank you
m by Wayman Griffin had to step out
briefly
so Vice chairman of the committee andary
pH temporarily filling in are there any
questions from M Kelby from those
members of the committee here in the
room anyone on uh online any of the
committee members observing to zoom any
question from
this seeing none again thank you very
much for your testimony thank
you okay no one else has signed up to
speak on this particular piece of
legislation uh is there anyone uh who
would like to um we have not called upon
as
yet can I can I clarify something Mr
sure so Hill thank you uh Mr Mr chairman
um if you look at uh lines one and two
of the bill um where it indicates that
this new section is being inserted after
section
17A the what what OS did was simply copy
the language from 17A which is
existing language and that's where the
signature guarantee part that they're
talking about in in Roman numeral 3
that's where it already exists so what
they're talking about is is already
existing law as far as signature
guarantee it has nothing to do with this
new section that's
being being completed does that make
sense
you're you're they just
transposed a uh 17A into into 17b and
then they Chang this language just
dealing with um mail in absentee voters
so the signature comparison that's
already in law that's already a subject
of of discussion but it has nothing to
do with with what this bill
does that's all thank you for that
clarification thank you
any other questions yes representative
yes U thank you chairman uh
representative Hill so do I understand
correctly then that that of this bill
section one is what's being changed in
section two and three are in existing
law already that is correct thank
you any other questions yes represent
thank you
sir
are
there concerns that you have about
possible bot Haring
that
um thank you for your question
representative um I always have concerns
about ballot harvesting um this bill
would
certainly um lend an air of um
reliability if if a town can certainly
know at this point um whether the
request that comes in by mail is
actually being uh requested by the
person um that shows up on that
checklist um currently um you know I
have my town clerk who will say but I
know every single person in the town
that's requesting the absentee ballots
and I'll say well that's great you may
know that person but you don't know that
it's that person that is doing the
requesting it may be um you know Peggy
in Islamabad that's doing the requesting
for someone um in town that you have no
idea and and she will finally we have to
agree to disagree um because she feels
that she knows every single person so in
that way yes ballot harvesting I think
would be
limited thank you for your question
thank you anyone else have a question on
the committee for representative Hill
yes um representative blae you have your
hand up yes thank you um representative
Hill as I think someone pointed out um
there is a provision now that is a
felony to do this H fraud that you're so
concerned about do you not feel that
that's sufficient to deter
fraud thank you for your question
um I um I do not feel that that is uh
sufficient and for the reason that this
is a very difficult um situation to
determine uh for the reasons that I
stated that um very few people ever
don't vote in an election and then go
back to check to the the checklist used
on the day of the election to determine
whether someone voted their ballot um it
it goes
undetectable um and that's part of the
concern I have and part of the reason
that I filed the bill that you will hear
after the next one which uh in sequence
was really supposed to go first which
was House Bill
291 um so I think I can probably answer
better when I get to 291 that that
concern
thank you you thank you anyone else with
a
question committee room anyone on Zoom
yes our
representative thank you kindly Mr chair
I um wanted to inquire about um The
Proposition that this uh well really the
combined proposition that this kind of
fraud is rampant on one hand and
entirely undetected on the other and um
and I wondered if there's you know if
there is any positive evidence that the
incidence of this fraud is
significant um thank you for your
question I um I am in no way um
suggesting that this is rampant I'm
saying the possibility um is very easy
for someone who isn't as bright as me um
if I can figure out how I would build a
list of names of people that um probably
will not be voting in the next election
and I have figured out how it is
possible for for someone to request
absentee ballots by mail for that
specific person on those list that I
could build and have that ballot mailed
anywhere in the United States and have
very little chance of detection I think
it is something that we need to be
concerned with and I think it's
something that we can uh with very minor
uh tweaks to the existing law uh I think
we can um alleviate the concern or at
least mitigate the discern so that would
be my answer to your question thank you
sir thank
you anyone else any other questions from
the
committee anyone here in the committee
room anyone watching on zooming by
Zoom seeing no one
all testimon and all the questions thank
you representative H thank you I'll see
you in a few
minutes so with that I'm going to be
there are no other people to testify to
close out the hearing on this particular
piece of
legislation with
me paper
in closing out the testimony on House
Bill 292 and I am opening the hearing
the public hearing on House Bill
327 requiring the voters show
identification and personally delivering
absente ballot to and city clerk
representative the prime sponsor on this
legislation like
to thank you
sir thank you members of my favorite
committee
um this bill was was brought to my
attention during uh this year when we
had a lot of the uh pre-processing of
absente ballots our town clerk mentioned
to me um that it would be you know more
consistent if uh those who were dropping
off I'm sorry the town moderator not
sorry uh if those who were dropping off
absentee ballots in person were also
required to show ID just as people who
vote in person show
ID so um that's why this this bill was
drafted and I tried to come up with a
way that uh would be simple and easy to
um Implement in real life so um this is
why it says that the clerk shall Mark
the absentee ballot affidavit envelope
with the notation AIP PS appeared in
person ID shown and voter verified and
note on the clerk's list of absentee
voters that the voter has been verified
the verified voter signatures on the
application for the absentee ballot
shall not be compared to the voter
signature on the absent ballot affidavit
on Election Day and of course that's out
of reflection of the 2018 ruling that we
discussed earlier today
and uh I am open for questions I think
this is pretty simple
itself okay questions for
representative yes representative thank
you Mr chair thank you representative
taking the question
so basically what this legislation will
do is bring in to agreement the
requirement to
show
identification uh like you have to do
now if you come in to vote in person
simply that same requirement that exists
for drop off youram ballot
Bally thank you
yes anyone else in the committee room
question for
representative'
representative
representative thank you thank you
representative um representative pudm
O'Brien and this isn't directed on your
Amendment which is very minor um the
original text of the law the statute
says the clerk shall mark the absentee
ballot affidavit
envelope um there's another provision in
state law
6578 which says all such envelopes shall
be preserved unopened until Election Day
do you know how the clerks are handling
this now if they're not supposed to be
opening the outer envelope to get to the
affidavit envelope are they actually
doing that or are they making the
notation on the outer envelope that's
delivered to the uh town clerk's
office I'm not really sure um
what as it's listed it's the affidavit
envelope that would be
marked yes yeah that's what the current
law says I'm I'm just confused I I I'll
ask some questions it doesn't take away
from what you're proposing I'm just uh
wondering if the existing statute might
also need to be slightly uh
amended but thank you very much thank
you I will I will think of that thank
you
sir
representative
Lane um thank you uh what if they do not
have ID um and as a followup would we
allow them to do an affidavit the way we
do uh when they come to vote in
person thank you representative Lane
that's a good
question I think that um they would be
treated the same as if they did not have
ID when they arrived at the polling
place no
yes now my my just to add to that my um
Town moderator did ask people when when
they had not filled things out correctly
uh she did let them know and was able to
alert a few people that they had not
filled out their their ballots correctly
and they came down and when when she did
so this was during pre-process
processing she asked if they would show
their ID and there was no problem with
that process that I saw I saw that they
wanted to be asked the voters that were
there wanted to be asked for their ID
they consistently told told us that they
were happy to have been asked and they
all had IDs and there was not a problem
with anyone who did not have one in my
community yes I was asked too and
pointed out to them that wasn't required
they weren't very happy with
me any other questions for
representative
o' in the committee room or
representative plan are you all
set your
hand okay I um I'm looking at the list
of attendees I don't see anyone with a
hand up is there anyone I have not
called upon who might want to
testify David Stan Deputy Stan go
ahead thank you thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee I'm David
scanland deputy secretary of state and I
just like to transfer a little
perspective on the last two bills that
that just heard um you know I think
everybody that sits on this committee
understands how polarized uh the
political parties have become and that
is certainly reflected now uh in our
elections and and legislation that's
being proposed and you know we cannot
show that there is widespread voter
fraud uh taking place in New Hampshire
and we cannot show that there is
widespread voter suppression taking
place here either but on either end of
that Spectrum there are significant
numbers of our citizens in the state
that believe that to be the case one
hand you have people that believe that
there is absolutely voter fraud going on
and on the other side of that coin you
have people that believe that that
there's voter suppression that is being
attempted and taking
place anything that we can do to help
instill confidence in both directions uh
uh in elections is only going to help us
uh maintain the confidence uh that
people used to have and you know I have
to admit it's you know that confidence
is starting to uh to waver a little bit
uh with events that uh have transpired
so um the example that I will use is
that back in 2012 we passed a a voter ID
law where uh you know voters going in
are required to show an acceptable form
of ID if they don't have it there is an
alternative way that uh they can easily
still obtain their ballot and cast their
vote um I think the same thing uh should
take place the absentee balloting
process and if we require voters on the
day of the election to show an ID it's
only appropriate that uh voters um at
least voluntarily be offered the
opportunity to do just that and I think
by doing so we will help instill that
confidence uh in voters without creating
an undue burden on the process of
allowing them to be able to exercise
their right to vote so with that Mr
chairman I'd be happy to answer any
questions
thank you Deputy scan and is there
any questions for Mr SC scanland
representative waye do you have a
question yes I do um I wouldn't normally
do this but why we instill confidence by
stating that the claims of fraud are not
based on evidence rather than succumbing
to the perpetuation of
Lies uh representative Lane uh there is
evidence that there are isolated
instances of inappropriate voting uh in
the state of New Hampshire I don't think
we can deny we also have a large segment
of our
population that for whatever reason
believes that it is happening and we
cannot ignore the perception because
that leads to the the confidence that
voters have we have to be willing to
address that and to the extent that we
are able to do that and not impinge on
their right to vote I guess to the other
side of the coin that you know there's
people that believe that you know a lot
of these bills are being offered to uh
you know to push forward voter
suppression and we haven't seen that in
a widespread way either um does it
happen on a small scale uh perhaps but
there are people that believe that and
we have to deal with that perception and
if we can do that and we can we can put
mechanisms in place that allow voters to
uh believe that the process is uh easy
for them to vote but it is also allowing
those people who are qualified to vote
exercise those rights uh that's to
everybody's
benefit representative bar I'm sorry
could I have a followup follow up
sorry do you think that these Provisions
are going to eliminate fraud I mean is
there a way to eliminate
fraud
uh I never said that these Provisions
would eliminate fraud I think that what
these what these uh Provisions do is uh
allow an opportunity for a voter to uh
easily show that they are who they say
they are and that the this gives the
clerk the opportunity to to pre verify
an absentee ballot which helps on the
day of the election and by doing that
you know we we take a step down the road
to instilling more confidence in our
process you set representative
Lane I'm done for
today yeah because there was I
representative bar uh yes Deputy Stan
thank you for your testimony today um
you and I have had a lot of discussions
about this issue um around the about V
of fraud perception of fraud the
definition of fraud is um not going to
try to read that today um but I do have
a question along um what represented
Lane was referring to um the state does
have a compelling interest not to
suppress the vote and has a compelling
interest can vote but I do have a
question which is do you believe that by
having as loose voter laws as we do
particularly around the lack of actual
ID that is required you believe that
there is some voter suppression by vote
by people who would otherwise vote but
are now disenfranchised because they
don't believe in the process
anymore I'm sorry representative Barry I
I did my best to try and understand the
question but I had a difficult time
hearing you so um it could be because
your mask is on and it's muffled um uh
but if you could or somebody could
repeat the question that would be
helpful my my question secretary scandin
is do you think that there are people
that do not vote because they do not
have faith in our
elections uh there may be some uh
representa Barry however you know our
record speaks for itself you know the
percentage of turnout that we have in
our elections is consistently uh in the
top tier in the country and top tier is
top three and so you know New Hampshire
despite you know the the sentiment out
there is is one of the easiest places to
vote uh in the United States and we bear
that out uh election after election and
uh but we do have these underpinings we
we have these undercurrents of of uh you
know beliefs out there that that maybe
more perception than they are reality
and and I'm just saying that we have to
be aware of that and and uh and take
steps to address it before it becomes a
bigger
thank you representative ter thank you
madam chair thank you Deputy scan for
taking the
question
so in
addition this bill giving increased
voter
confidence uh in the process would it
not also be a good idea to align or
bring consistency consistency between
in-person voting and AP balloting by
that I mean um this would bring the same
requirement to show an ID that is
required in person would that be good to
have that
consistency yes I I think to the extent
that the voting
experience is uh similar to what all
other voters experience is uh you know
is a goal that we should strive for but
you know with that said I think we do
have to recognize that you know the
process of people voting by absentee
because they cannot make it to the poing
place is going to be different
inherently
uh than showing up at the polls and
voting but but to the extent that we can
have uniform uh standards uh in the
process of voting that's a positive
thing thank you other questions for
Deputy scanland representative
Mir thank you madam chair um my my
understanding of your testimony is that
the Secretary of State's office supports
this legislation because it will
increase confidence in the fairness and
integrity of
elections um and I wonder um H is there
evidence that the passage of voter ID
laws in recent sessions has in fact had
the effect of increasing confidence in
the fairness of
Elections uh is there evidence that we
can point to you know I I'm not aware of
a a report or a white paper that anybody
has written uh to that effect however um
when the voter ID law was being debated
it was very controversial it was very
similar to what this conversation that
we're having today and there were claims
that there were going to be 10% of the
population that did not have a voter ID
and the reality is within two years
after people got used to it it is an
nonissue and it it's it is a fraction of
1% of the people that show up at the
polls now and do not present some form
of acceptable ID that was a success
story it it it buil confidence I mean
there were people prior to that bill
passing saying I cannot believe that you
know that I don't have to show an ID to
go to the you know to to get my ballot
um that instilled confidence and and it
is a non-issue after the fact and and
what I'm saying is that if we can
provide opportunities like this for
people in this case to voluntarily offer
credentials uh and not uh in not make it
more difficult for them to actually vote
that's a positive thing it instills
confidence representative
B yes thank you madam chairman uh Deputy
scanland my question pertains to the
language of the bill House Bill
327 um the bill proposes to amend
section two of RSA 6571
17A section one says that the voter can
prove identity by one providing photo
identification or two completing a
challenge voter affid
davit this amendment uses the word and
um the person the envelope is going to
be mark saying the person appeared in
person and showed an ID and is voter
verify should that be or uh so that it's
clear that the person chose to proof
prove identity either by showing an ID
or by filling out the challenged voter
affidavit yes yeah I I would agree with
that and I and I think if you know that
language actually referred back to
section one and just said you know
either a or b um you know it would
effectively do the same thing but I I
agree with you and Madame chairman
follow-up question representative bers
um also the question I posed to the
sponsor about marking this information
on the absentee ballot affidavit
envelope do you know how that's handled
now if the clerks aren't supposed to be
opening the outer envelope
anyway uh I I think you raised a really
valid point um I mean at that point the
only the only envelope that should be
accessible to the clerk is the you know
the outer
although
um I'm only hesitating because if they
are if they are at that point doing it
in person uh at the clerk's office I
mean there may be an opportunity to to
write it on the affidavit envelope but I
think that's an area that they could use
a little further
review okay thank you no further
questions question from committee
members room or participating
El I'm not seeing any thank you Deputy
scanland I do have people in attendance
is there anybody else who' like to
submit comment on house bu
327 I'm not seeing any thank you I'm
going to close the hearing on
327 House Bill
291 i' say
we 156 I don't know I'm gonna leave it
up to you guys what do you think 156 am
I close enough to two to go or do I need
to wait a couple of minutes I think we
need to wait all right we'll just stay
on
and in a couple minutes we'll do
back
[Music]
M chairman we're
unmuted all right it is 2 o'cl everybody
it is 2 o' new hure house election
committee the public hearing scheduled
for today Thursday
2421 at 2:00 is HB 291 relative to the
public ins inspection of absentee ballot
list the prime sponsor representative
Hill joins us in committee room to
introduce his bill welcome
representative Hill thank you madam
chair uh for the record once again I am
uh representative Greg Hill I serve
marac 3 which is the town of Northfield
onethird of the city of Franklin uh I'm
here to introduce house bille
291 um which um deals still and
specifically with that slice of the uh
of the voting public um mailin absentee
ballots um this is uh the prior bill
that I spoke on uh host Bill 292 dealt
with um future voters um this bill deals
with after the fact a after uh voters
have voted um and the review of the U
absentee ballots and where those
absentee ballots were sent um when I
last served on house election law um I
was reviewing um this section of the of
the rsas and I was surprised to see that
um that the information of where
absentee ballots are mailed um is is
done behind the veil of
secrecy um in fact if you look on on the
bill um line
18 um actually it starts on line
17 the the true language of the law says
uh the list which is U referring to the
list of where um ballots are mailed by
the clerks shall be available for public
uh inspection um with a court order so
someone in in order to determine where
um an absentee ballot has been mailed
has to go and get a court order and that
includes the Secretary of State um which
I'm glad to see that Deputy stanland is
uh is available and hopefully he
testifies behind me um he and I uh back
in
2019 um requested the uh the Hava
Personnel um to do a report and um and
they did and they went uh and sat us
down in at Fruit Street in conquer
although it's not called Fruit Street
anymore I forget what it is called um
and they will um and they went through
the results of uh where absentee ballots
were mailed U to addresses outside New
Hampshire that was the the specific
request I had made where were these
ballots being mailed and and so it
turned out U that
14,46 absentee ballots in the 2016
presidential election were mailed to
addresses outside New Hampshire that
does not include any that were military
U aava diplomatic any of that um so this
these are just strict
14,46 ballots that were mailed to
outside addresses and we had asked um
for an analysis whether there are any
common addresses um where these ballots
were sent where multiple ballots went to
the same
address Well turns out they are um and
so we received back um in this
report I just wanted to Quick T face Mr
o'briant thank you go ahead um we found
that roughly uh 1,400 or 10% of those
ballots um were sent to Common
addresses um multiple times so um for
instance 100 times New Hampshire town
clerks mailed at least three ballots to
the to a same physical address um and
I'll just scan through this list and
give you examples
um 68 times four ballots were sent to
the same physical address 12 times six
ballots were sent to the same physical
address outside New Hampshire 13 times
eight ballots were sent to the same
address nine times 10 ballots were sent
to the same physical address outside New
Hampshire four times 14 ballots were
sent and I'm skipping I go along here uh
three times 19 ballots were sent to the
same physical address add two times 21
ballots were sent to the same physical
address and once the winner is 23
ballots went to the same outside New
Hampshire address and we don't know
where that address is and we would only
know if we had a court order um allowing
that information to be known so this
bill does one thing it strikes that word
not and it uh allows 60 days after the
election that information to be
available to the public I wouldn't care
if it's 60 days 90 days or 365 days it
doesn't matter to me the point is for me
that that information should be at some
point available for um anyone but mostly
in this bill the Secretary of State who
should be able to um look at that
information and um determine at that
point whether anything needs further
investigation um I testified in the
prior uh bill that um it would be very
easy for someone to gain um a list of
names uh and request absentee ballots
for those those names and be virtually
assured of never being
caught I'm not saying in any way shape
or form that these B
that went to the same physical address
anywhere in the United States are by any
chance proof of fraud I am suggesting
that it is proof of Investigation there
should be somebody looking at where
these went um you know we would have and
and some of the examples that I received
back from the Hava people were that um
you know it's entirely possible that
some of these may have gone to
retirement communities or College
or any a couple of other examples that
they had anywhere in the United States
and it would explain why that they why
there would be similar ballots or
similar addresses with ballots going to
that same address all true all true it
is possible that that's true but let's
say it is a college and and um and yet
after the investigation we find out that
23 ballots went to one dorm room in that
College should be um give us pause at
any rate um so just saying oh well this
is a college and that's the explanation
for it doesn't work for me um so I'm
asking in this bill that the secretary
of state would be able to have access to
this information and provide a report
that would show those four items and for
me I won't go through all of them but D
is the one that that um is the most
important to me and that says for the
most common addresses as determined by
the number of ballots sent to that
address the actual addresses where the
ballots were mailed needs to be known um
that's that to me is um is the the money
shot in this that's the reason we're
doing that um so I with that I will be
happy to answer any questions about um
about the research we did or the bill um
thank you representative Hill questions
from committee members
representative I do think
representative hand up first go
ahead so my question then is are you
talking
about out ofate addresses and I have
a I I thank you um representative um the
the test the examples that I use were
specifically to um addresses outside New
Hampshire I do know that Deputy scanland
asked for a followup to investigate
whether any multiple ballots were sent
inside New Hampshire I never have seen
the the results of that request um and I
do know the the examples I was showing
were for the 2016 election I do know um
in conversations with Deputy scanland
that he's asked for the information from
this prior presidential election as well
but yes I was only talking about outside
New Hampshire that CeX were going thank
you representative to back to you thank
you chair um I was gonna ask a similar
question my question
was
currently current statute can you
request information
for sent to inside
addresses um again this is the current
law does not allow it without um a court
order so for any whether it's inside
outside okay that's what I wanted up and
down any of those things
yeah thank you for your
question representative
Lane yes thank you madam chair um the
question that I directed to you
representative
hill before would you like to answer
that one now I would be happy to can can
you me what the question
was I'm 60 you know these things oh well
I'm older so you
know uh but I think it was more along
the lines of what evidence of fraud is
there and are we putting forth A
solution that is in search of a
problem um thank you for your question
and uh and I do remember it
now but it um I I again I think as I I
offer here and as I said this is not
proof of fraud um this is this is merely
um in an effort to um to um increase
transparency um and and shed a little
sunlight on some of this um and
certainly Deputy I agree with Deputy
scanlan's comments about um um adding
some measure of um of certain toe to uh
to people that are voting um it was
possible for me to get this this list of
information and I know you can't read it
but the list um of where these multiple
ballots have gone is is takes up about
half the page um I just think that that
um is worthy of Investigation but I I
said clearly that it is not proof of
fraud could I have a followup please
sure who who is doing the investigation
I I guess maybe I didn't read the bill
who is doing that investigation what
what do you do with this information
when you get it um so in the bill um it
requires the Secretary of State to
provide the
report but once that report is that the
investigation that you're requesting is
simply that
information um no that report would then
be sent and
I um jumped ahead sorry um the uh I'm
I'm asking that the uh secretary of
state would um would create this report
and I'm trying to
[Music]
see where it says that the report goes I
I would have expected it to go to um the
election law chairs um and the Senate
President and the speaker of the house
but I don't see it listed so I will make
a
note thank you for your
question thank you uh representative
Brian did you still have a followup yes
I do thank you ma'am um so my my
question representa Phil yes if these
are out ofate
addresses what do
you imagine the problem could be that
say it's going to New Hampshire
residents who are at Harvard University
which is out of state or Yale University
out state but in the same building would
that be listed as the same address would
that be two3 Main Street Cambridge
Massachusetts and then that's why it
looks like the same address um thank you
for your
question I'm afraid I can't be very
specific with the answer um I'm only
taking the the information from the hob
people who investigated it and and it
was their determination what whether
that was the same address or not um it
it may have just said Harvard I don't
know um we we never did see the
addresses we were told however that um
you know one was an RV park one was a
college interestingly one of them was a
um was a highr rather expensive
high-rise apartment building in Boston
um but we don't know the address or why
um ballots would be sent to that address
so the investigation has never gone
beyond just just knowing from the Hava
people that it was a common address and
and how many ballots went
there thank you for the followup
representative thank you Madame chairman
uh
representative I could certainly
understand the value of of this type of
report uh to the Secretary of State's
office and perhaps the Attorney
General's office for internal use and
and investigation purposes but at what
point does publishing people's addresses
start to infringe on their right to
privacy uh you know our constitution
says that an individual is has a right
to live free from governmental intrusion
and private or personal information um
what value is there in taking this
information and making it public
when its purpose and its use should be
driven by the needs of the Secretary of
State and the Attorney General's
office uh thankks for your question um I
will tell you that years ago um before
this was um only available by court
order um the practice used to be that
the clerk would um create a list of
names of where she had sent absente
ballots and posted on the door of the uh
of the clerk's office and and and it was
only at that point that someone pointed
out it was a great tool for burglar to
use to know that somebody wasn't going
to be at that address and and that would
be a great place to go but at that I
guess I point that out to say that um
you
know it's it's not very difficult to um
to have a list of addresses you can do
it with if they still publish telephone
books I don't know um but uh
but having a place where 23 ballots were
sent to a single address
um you know I I I would have no problem
quite frankly if if the bill was amended
so that the Secretary of State and the
Attorney General had it that was the
reason I I delineated the Secretary of
State in here um but I I have always uh
deferred to the idea of sunshine being
the greatest expected so um I would I
would make the information known um
publicly okay thank you no further
questions thank you representative
representative Cody H yes thank you
madam chair representative Hill um the
document to which you are referring what
what what is the provence of that
document from which you're deriving this
information is that a document that was
the result of a report or I'm a little
confused as to what the provence of it
was uh thank you representative Cody
nice to see you again um it is uh this
was a request uh that was made as I was
sitting as Vice chair of this committee
um by through um deputy scanland and it
was um it was created uh by the Hava
people on Constitution have I think it
is actually now um and uh and so it it
wasn't a report that went anywhere that
I'm aware um unless Deputy scanland um
did anything with it that I'm unaware of
uh could you Poss uh sorry madam chair I
further question um could you possibly
provide a copy of that material to the
committee
absolutely um I mailed yes I emailed
yesterday at 4 something in the
afternoon um to the committee a list of
all of the
uh
uh the number apprciate that I
appreciate that represented but I'm
referring specifically to to the the
full document yes here here this is the
single document that I have it's one
page that um that was created um that
shows those numbers on here but it was
such small print that that's why I I
created my own document with larger font
because again I'm 60 so representative
Cody is that the piece of paper that you
want and we'll ask representative Hill
to scan it and send it to us yes I think
that would be helpful thank you madam
chair excellent I will do that okay
thank you
representative representative Phil uh do
you foresee that this would in any way
suppress voter
vote I we it bite by simply Shining
Light on the addresses where Bill and
ballot went would that have the impact
of suppressing vote you believe um or
should it um thank you for your question
I have no idea why it would I can't
sitting here think of a reason why it
would um I think
it's I think it's just um information of
of where multiple ballots are being sent
um not not in any way shape or form an
idea of suppressing the
vote might it suppressed the vote
slightly of 23 ballots shouldn't have
gone to that
address clarification this is a a report
after the election correct correct okay
representative Ward do you have a
question I do thank you madam chair and
thank you representative Hill for uh
taking my question you may have answered
this before but I wonder if you could
Define with a little more specificity
what you mean by Common address same
street number same town same zip code um
thank you very much
um I'm not
sure if I recall the exact language that
Deputy scanland used he may recall um if
he testifies after me what what was
given to the Hava people in order to
generate this um I don't recall them
ever getting to the specificity of of
what what was detailed but we were
talking about um a single address where
multiple ballots had gone now you know
if you think about a college it is
possible that colleges have their own
mail room so one address may go to a
single uh or one mailing may go to a
single mail room and for multiple
students um so that that was my
indication that um and that's why I say
this is not proof of anything um it's
just a fodder for further
investigation I hope that answers the
question yeah thank you thank you for
the question from members of the
committee in room Deputy scanland has
his hand raised scanland
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee uh once again I'm David
scanland deputy secretary of state uh
not taking a position on this bill but I
would like to just get let the committee
have a little history and maybe
clarification on what we're talking
about here um the the Statewide
centralized voter database known as
election net uh was a requirement of the
help America vote act that passed in
2002 and it required uh the state it
required every state to create such a
database if they did not already have
one and it required certain items um a
lot of personal information related to
the voter uh be kept in that
database when the legislature the New
Hampshire legislature created the
database or authorized it they said very
clearly that the that the personal
information of the voter was to remain
confidential the it was built with the
barn doors closed and if any of you know
uh represent Neil Kirk um a really
strong privacy Advocate was chair of the
finance committee for a number of years
uh saw to it that those protections were
in
place um at some subsequent uh bium the
legislature did loosen up the uh the
database to allow for uh the
distribution of public check L uh
allowing the Secretary of State to sell
a Statewide list to political parties uh
uh political committees registered in
New Hampshire and to political
candidates and for candidates we could
produce the list for the candidates
District but uh we could not break it
down any more than that any member of
the public any citizen of New Hampshire
that wanted to obtain a list could go to
their Town Clerk or supervisors of the
checklist and purchase that list
directly from uh that person for just
that uh uh political
subdivision the um the legislature then
said
um uh well so as as part of that the the
clerks then during election season
received the absentee ballot requests uh
and they keep a list of that and they
keep track of when the request was
received when the ballot got naed out
when it comes back and whether it was
actually counted or not in the
election those lists are also
confidential that information is put in
election net but the information is kept
at the clerk's office and the law says
that that information is also
confidential information except that a
candidate who is running for office can
obtain that list of Voters so that they
can communicate uh with the voter um and
send them information but no other
member of the public uh is authorized to
obtain that list after the election is
over and we have elected officials but
at that point we have no candidates that
list is uh no longer
available uh unless there's a court
order uh you know to obtain that
list what what uh representative Hill
requested uh when he was vice chair of
the committee was information in
aggregate form uh related to uh absentee
ballots that were sent to the same
address multiple times and the report
that we generated uh at for that request
was was an aggregate request there was
no voter identification I tied to it uh
I I don't think the addresses were
available it was simply numbers saying
that there were you know 10 ballots sent
to uh you know 21 you know whatever the
number was um and and that is the list
that representative Hill is referring to
and and we will produce uh reports based
on aggregate information that are that
are aggregate in form based on
information in the database um you know
if it's helpful to A legislature or
committee to you know understand issues
but we do not in any uh instance uh
provide private and confidential
information about the voters themselves
their addresses or you know anything uh
anything else that's related so I think
it's important that that me may be be
made
clear I will end by saying that this uh
is policy that is in the domain of the
legislature and uh we will um
vigorously uh protect the private and
confidential information of the voters
that are in that database and if there
is legislation that comes forward that
says somehow that we should be releasing
that information uh we
will uh very strongly oppose it however
to the extent that you know the
committee believes it reports in
aggregate form or uh you know if there's
an expansion of who is entitled to have
the public
checklist um you know those those are
your decisions to make and you know we
will uh obviously
um abide by whatever the legislature
decides in that respect so with that
Madam chair I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you does anybody have
any questions forut
SC thank you madam chair thank you again
Deputy scalan I had a question in regard
to the voter list that um a candidate
can get from the town clerk of where
they are
candidate it's my understanding is
you're stated that you get that list for
those addresses but if they if the voter
has a PO Box you can only get the street
address you can't get the PO Box is that
accurate is that correct statement uh I
I would have to go back and actually
look at the statute I think what the
clerk um can provide is the name of the
voter and uh and either their mailing or
physical address those that that's
public
information um they will not provide the
address where the absentee ballot is
being sent to if it is a location other
than what is on the uh on the checklist
that's my understanding of that statute
thank
[Music]
youline I'm not seeing any thank you
Deputy scan thank you I don't have
anybody else signed up to testify in
regards to House Bill 291 is there
anybody else who would just see to this
bill I'm not seeing anybody so I'm going
to close the hearing on House Bill 291
and open the hearing that was supposed
to begin 15 minutes ago too late on
House Bill
406 this is relative to the ability of
the public to observe the processing and
Counting of absentee ballots um I don't
have anybody signed up to speak to this
bill but I understand representative PR
home O'Brien can speak to HP
to to the FL and I just asked that you
sign up tonight online to show
that thank you thank you um Madame
chairwoman and and the
committee this bill uh I I passed out
some uh diagrams for you all to
show the setup of the area where the
pre-processing of fent ballots was done
this earlier this year in Derry and it
may be hard for you to um visualize that
so I will take something that's similar
in
size this is about the same size and the
absentee ballots were Pro processed and
vared all right with a
if you don't mind because we're doing
this sort of hybrid and I think you were
able to pass out things to committee
members but members did not the bill as
proposed for which you are a sponsor
proposes specific language that the
members of the public shall be committed
to observe the processing and Counting
of abente ballots without obstruction
and from a distance of six feet from
such across the sing County correct
correct it's all about being able to see
the the um processing of the of the
absentee ballot and so when you have a a
a partition between yourself and you're
the if you're the Publican and something
between you can't see anything that's
happening behind that partition I don't
think that there was anything the fair
is planned with the setup that we that I
saw that I I saw and one of the other
sponsors saw for this I think it's just
that that was a very convenient place to
do the absentee ballot pre-processing
but
every RSA that we have uh regarding this
is about transparency and about the
public being able to see what's
happening in real time and for that
reason this is uh something that that
myself and the other um sponsors thought
was important to clarify in state law
because it had not been uh so again like
there was nothing nefarious that I'm
aware of it's just wasen place to to do
the pre-processing but it wasn't truly
as transparent as I think the spirit of
every other law um dictates that we have
regarding ballot processing all
right I hope that's clear and I hope
that the the diagrams that everybody has
well but nobody online can see so I'm
gonna make an attempt here for committee
members who are viewing this online I
don't know if you can see if you the
Town Council room in Dairy it's my
recollection because I watched these
meetings almost looks like a courtroom
you walk into it and there's actually
two bays of seating as you enter the
room and then at the front of the room
there's a half circle of a table that if
it was straight would look across like a
Judicial bench where Town Council
Members sit behind it to conduct
business while the camera is looking at
them and in front of and that this
platform sits on about 8 Ines according
to the diagram and so you're aware
because I actually did think it was a
courtroom the first time I took a look
at it real quick at the front of the
bench with the members sitting behind it
it is
elevated um with a piece of wood I think
that's actually I don't know six to 10
inches that goes all the way around so
it would be a there was a ledge right
here in front of us so you would not be
able to see my scribbling on the paper
we turning the page that's an excellent
description representative okay yeah so
so this is what representative O'Brien
she she passed out this diagram in
regards to how the Town Council room is
set up and that's where apparently they
did the processing correct yes all right
yes it's it's it's a convenient place to
do the processing I I can understand why
they were chosen
that you couldn't see anything okay but
I could we could not see where what was
happening with B all right thank you any
questions for representative
Brian I'm not any questions for people
attending oh sorry I missed it
representative Lane oh sorry it's in
real I'm looking for my little I'm sorry
I wasn't fast enough so thank you um
in my ward where we usually vote um I'm
not sure that it can be configured to do
that within six feet and have it's such
a tiny spot so I guess I just raised
that from my own personal experience is
there some wiggle room um I mean they'd
have to be really close or they have to
stand really far away I and I guess I I
don't know if ours is unusual or what
but it it is very difficult for them to
maneuver as it
is so thank you is that was that a
question uh is it is it I guess is it
possible to do
something I don't know if they can do
six feet because I mean it it would have
to probably
be longer than that wider way than that
just because of the physical constraints
of of everything else that they've got
going
on well thank you representative Lane
for that
um every Situation's a little different
in our state I think we're all familiar
with that that that every U town hall or
or Municipal Center or school is
different than the other ones but we do
try to have some unification in law so
that all of our citizens will um have
the same expectations and the same
treatment when they try to observe the
um the counting of and the processing of
of ballots and of the absentee ballots I
don't think that this it's too much to
ask to not have a lip on the desk like a
a reception desk we're all maybe
familiar with the governor's reception
desk it's like that and I like to call
this in in simple terms I call this the
hands where I can see them bill because
we should be able to see what's going on
with the
ballots
so me for interrupting I guess in
followup to attorney Lane's question it
doesn't sound like the six feet was the
issue the issue was you couldn't see the
hands right it could be one foot it
would still be a problem could be eight
feet right the six feet is
not the distance was not the issue it
wasn't as if you were me showing up
without your glasses at 6 Fe and
couldn't see what they were doing the
issue was you couldn't see the hands
right you couldn't you couldn't watch
meaningfully the actual process there
are Provisions where six feet is is is
uh indicated because that's far enough
away for you to see what's happening
with the ballot but you're not so close
that you're seeing that your neighbor
Mrs Smith voted a certain way you're not
seeing the ballots that close all right
but I guess the question is
representative Bri
is if the six speak was if the distance
minimum was eliminated from this bill
given that there are other Provisions in
Statute in regards to the ability to
observe does that make the bill
meaningless to you or is the main
provision that you can actually see the
processing without
obstruction that is the main point the
the not having obstruction okay thank
you all right other questions I have a
couple other hands but I don't see any
other
questions
um Deputy scanland you have your hand
up thank you madam chair once again
members of the committee I'm David
scanland deputy secretary of state um
the the sponsor in this bill uh
explained the situation that you just uh
showed visually in that chart and uh it
it did not seem right um you there
should be transparency in this process
and uh we would certainly support that
um I think the six foot figure may have
come in there because there is a
requirement uh at the voter registration
table that uh that observers cannot get
any closer than six feet to that process
but I did want to comment on the way
this uh this amendment is written uh
because it says members of the public
shall be permitted to observe the
processing and Counting of absentee
ballots without obstruction and from a
distance of six feet from such
processing and counting to me that means
that every member that wants to observe
that process should be able to be six
feet away and uh as representative Lane
mentioned that may not be practical in
probably most polling places so um you
know I I think what is uh you know
what's important here is that that
process be transparent and that the
people that want to observe it can can
do so in a meaningful way and with that
I'd be happy to answer any
questions3 well I guess I I have a
question so Deputy scalin so is when you
say members of the public are
you insinuating that there should be a a
distinction between members of the
public and official
observers no what I'm saying is I I
don't think that it may not be practical
or possible for each member of the
public to be exactly six feet away
from the uh you know the the processing
of the absentee ballots which is what
that sentence seems to imply all right
your issue was not with the members of
the public piece of the SE section it
was with the six feet that's right okay
sorry I misinterpreted what you said
other questions from committee members
in attendance here or attending
online
I'm not seeing any um I don't have
anybody actually signed up anybody else
to speak on this bill um representative
love I think I saw you somewhere at one
point and I don't know where you've gone
um hold on let me check got an attend
with your hand
up my left hand isn't doing it
representative love indeed there you are
I apologize representative love you were
with us welcome
yeah I've done it a couple of times so
I okay sorry representative love we I
had a little technical difficulty you
are with us now if you were unmute you
were with
us is if anybody's upstairs I'm having
problems with getting representative
love no it says it's he's joining as a
panel
yeah he was there and then he went back
to attendees and I've just tried to move
him back in there he is there he is all
right thank you representative love
you're with us as a panelist if you
unmute we will be all
set there you go hello can you hear me
hello yes we can representative love
welcome I I I want to thank everybody
thank you madam chair and
and the uh the committee for for putting
up with my technology problems here and
uh thank you for to kathern prudom Brian
uh for for doing a good job uh
presenting this uh when representative
Lane was talking about uh you know the
the area at htown U you know the the
ward being too small and uh how can how
can you know on on one hand you're
talking about it's too small to have six
feet but you want it bigger if it's too
small it should be shrunk to four maybe
um you know um that that that doesn't
make much sense to me but uh you know
anyway um you know what happened here uh
is uh you know when I when I walked in I
you know I noticed that nobody could see
anything and uh you know I think six
feet is a a a a real good distance for
uh you can see what's going on uh you
know it it just lends the transparency
you know in this this day and age of
being uh you know we're we're being uh
inundated with new new technology new uh
new rules with the the um the uh
absentee ballots and uh you know where
at every turn something new is happening
that hasn't happened before uh we just
need a little Clarity and this brings
Clarity to the uh to the to the
statute thank you representative love
any questions for representative love
from the committee members or
people members attending
online me sorrya Lan I I I think
representative love rais is a good point
but it and it's hard to describe um what
what's going on is that we have so it's
such a tight space that we have a hard
time getting all the booths in and
spaces between the booths and getting
and having the 4 foot minimum that's
already
required you would have to stand outside
where the socalled checkin is and that
would probably be about 10 or 15 feet
and so the six feet because there isn't
a place that's six feet away that they
would be able to sit and do that without
actually being where the voting machine
is on top of it or in where the people
are voting it's just so tiny so you
would have to be in almost close to the
door where people walk in and that's
probably I'm guessing 10 to 15 feet so I
don't know if that makes it clearer but
I just think the six feet as long as
it's not instructed and you can see
what's going on I think it's a I think
there would be no I just I'm afraid the
six feet might be a problem for other
Wards like like
mine thank you representative Lane for
the comment I'm not sure that's a
question but it has caused me to ask a
question because you're right the fact
that you said booth made me think of
something because one talks about
counting a votes in this bill two talks
about a the processing and Counting I
don't think they were counting ballots
in the dairy Town Council room are you
talking about preprocessing yeah the
pre-processing so isn't it true then
that this bill would make more sense to
deviate the issues that representative
Lane is bring if it was to be permitted
to observe the pre-processing of
absentee ballots because they were not
counting the ballots that was the
preprocessing when you're doing them on
a election day you're at the polling
place and it was one representative Lane
said booth that I realized yeah wait a
minute we're talking about two different
procedures yeah I I think that
processing is is an effective processing
alone is effective in addressing the
issue no no no no I think the point is
representative Pomer bran the Town
Council room was only being used because
they were doing pre-processing if you're
at the polling place the ghouls already
apply as to where you stand and can
things yes yes so your intent was that
you didn't you had a
preprocessing procedure that nobody
could really
see yes ma'am I think that's accurate
and they were not count they were
pre-processing the absent of
balance that's an important distinction
and I thank you for bringing that up
okay all right makes sense now because
preprocessing sort of heard in a lot of
different places as Town's had and I can
see where maybe in some places they
didn't do
it where you can see it I think we have
a planning board counter that they might
have wanted to use that might not have
been if you were seated in a seat all
right any other questions from
anybody all right I'm not seeing any so
thank you to representative hant to
presenting another bill today thank you
to representative love um I going to
close the public hearing on house bille
406 and I'm going to open the public
hearing on HB
372 HB 372 is relative to the
enforcement of election laws the prime
sponsor on this is representative Max
Abramson and he is with us today to
present the bill welcome representative
Abramson I think if you unmute you will
be with us
all right are you able to hear me we are
let me see if I can make my video Work
might be too
dark oh okay I can see myself there you
are yes I'm still having problems with
these Zoom technology things that's what
happens when you pass
um so I'm I'm representative Max
Abramson uh representing Hampton Hampton
Falls in SE Brook and I'm introducing
House Bill 3 72 uh it currently under
our election laws um if somebody steals
your uh campaign sign um you go to the
police prosecutor and the with all the
evidence you could have I I've had other
legislators say they have the video they
have uh Witnesses they have their their
game cam you know the some neighbor
plants uh their campaign signed in their
front
yard and they catch somebody on video
you've probably seen the YouTube videos
where some somebody runs up and steals a
trump sign for example um that that was
a a big thing for a while and they catch
people on video they go to the police
prosecutor and the police prosecutor
says it's great you've got all the
you've got all the evidence right there
I could take this right to court but in
New Hampshire uh all of these election
law violations including stealing a
campaign sign goes through the Attorney
General's office so if you steal any
other sign that's not an election sign
then the police prosecutor can take it
but if you have so much as a a a sticker
that's uh advocating for any candidate
or issue um even if it's a local Town
warrant um then it becomes a political
sign and suddenly it goes to the
Attorney General's office so you'll call
the Attorney General's office over an
issue and I've had to call the Attorney
General's office uh once or twice I
received um some really serious threats
from some antifa people who are
threatening by violence um you'll you'll
contact them and they're very they're
very busy and they're certainly too busy
to handle something like campaign signs
being stolen so every time I've brought
this up with some of the other
legislators is certainly on the
Republican side almost every legislator
I talk to had some War Story during the
campaign process where there were sign
stolen or some other election law
violations and no one was able to
prosecute the case because only the
Attorney General's office can deal with
it can actually prosecute the case and
um even though they may have sufficient
evidence um they can't go forward with
an investigation so this bill
essentially would just allow County
attorneys U or Municipal prosecutors
usually from the police department to go
ahead and and and take these cases up um
the other much less common case is where
you have evidence of voter fraud and
what we're trying to do there is is um
essentially allow the county attorney's
office or police prosecutor to
investigate um we think that a majority
of
the um accusations or evidence of voter
fraud are just erroneous for example I
received a complaint as a legislator
this election that he saw the same
person come in twice at the same polling
place and he thought he was a volunteer
he thought that he saw the person cast
ballot
twice um again the County Attorney
office and the municipal prosecutor
might then have enough evidence to begin
an investigation but current statute
doesn't even allow them to investigate
or complete an investigation and submit
that to the AG's office everything has
to be handled through the AG's office um
and as as usually that's uh they're
they're much too busy so um where you
have cases where there's evidence in New
Hampshire in a particular town and it
mean may have police detail there so you
may have police officers as the witness
um and sometimes the police prosecutor
himself is there in which case he would
have to hand the case off because he's a
witness who would have to testify in
that case but whether it's a misdemeanor
violation or a
felony um we haven't been able to go
forward with these cases and just to
kind of um improve the security and uh
reliability and the faith that people
have in our elections uh process we want
to be sure that um people from out of
state who might be eyeing New Hampshire
as a as an opportunity to come in during
our presidential election
and um either cast a fraudulent Val
Ballot or as we've seen on video many
times people kind of drive in and steal
some yard signs um we want to put a stop
to that and I think the there's a need
for a deter deterring effect I was
contacted by about uh a dozen other
Republicans I've got a few co-sponsors
on this bill but about a dozen
Republicans said that they wanted to
co-sponsor this bill we just I I could
have filled this up if I wanted to make
a hobby of that but um it it certainly
is a problem at least the campaign signs
being stolen um there are lots of other
election laws um but those are the two
issues that that motivated uh
introducing this built so as usual I'll
take questions and I'm also as usual I'm
willing to uh go do the leg work and
introduce amendments for the
committee that is kind of dark isn't
it questions from committee members for
representative
abson either in the room or attending
electronically any questions oh I
probably should have uh mentioned in the
bill um if you go to I don't I don't
have it by a line number I just have the
bill it's um I think it's
section down at the bottom where it says
RSA 7 section 6-c which is just
enforcement um that the last line where
it says 668 section8 um RSA 7 section
34- is County attorneys and um this
would just add them in to that uh
enforcement and then RSA 41 section 10-a
U just deals with the powers of
Municipal prosecutors so a municipal
prosecutor is not allowed to prosecute
uh a felony case that would have to go
up to the county attorney's
office thank you for that clarification
that was on page three
day uh I have a question from
representative m
thank you madam chair I'm um wondering
if and I'm sorry if if you spoke to this
I'm trying to just keep up with
everything did um are the have you
spoken to County attorneys and are they
um welcoming this additional
responsibility and and similarly to the
attorney general welcome including the
County attorneys in in this enforcement
responsibility I I haven't spoken with u
County attorneys directly I've spoken
with um legisl whove said that they've
spoken with their uh Municipal
prosecutors who've then said they'd like
to be able to take up these cases
especially the stolen campaign signs
because they're not they're not able to
go forward even if they have all the
evidence even if they have witnesses in
video they're not able to go forward um
but the some of the municipal
prosecutors the police prosecutors um
would like to go forward with some of
these
cases representative
bo uh thank you madam chair it's been
asked and
answered anybody else questions for
representative
abon I'm not seeing any are there any
attendees who want to speak on this bill
uh I see that Kate hgan is with
us and has requested to speak as I
recall M hgan has submitted also written
testimony on beh of her client wel done
Miss thank you
uh chairman Griffin and members of the
committee my name is Kate Horan I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
Association of counties which includes
all your elected and appointed officials
including the County attorneys um to
just briefly follow up on the question
about whether or not the County
attorneys have the bandwidth to take
this on uh my discussions with them this
week they do not have the bandwidth to
take on this right now if you were
amable to amending the bill to removing
County attorneys and just leaving the
municipals uh we are perfectly fine with
that and we think that is probably a
more appropriate place um but I'm happy
to take any questions I just since the
question came up I wanted to make sure
we were on
record thank you very much any questions
from Miss Morgan I'm gonna turn it over
to representative McDonald have to leave
hearing this
afternoon any question from M Morgan yes
representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you very much for your testimony
and for taking my question uh when you
see that the uh County attorneys that
you've spoken to can't do the bandwidth
how much does the heavy reporting
requirements in this bill have to do
with that conclusion uh most of the
County attorneys figured that they would
need to hire additional staff to just
deal with the reporting requirements in
the bill um as you all can see requires
reporting about every six months um and
so as you might imagine county
attorney's uh budgets are very tight
right now and so they don't necessarily
believe they have the ability to hire
additional staff to do that
reporting thank
you any other questions from Miss
Moran anyone on line yes award uh thank
you for taking my question U Morgan the
actual um investigation part of it says
that the prosecutor May at his or her
discretion conduct the investigation so
if the reporting part of it were reduced
or eliminated would that then be
acceptable to your clients uh I would
have to take that back to them uh
representative but I'm happy to do so
and report back to the committee thank
you he I actually called on
representative Ward you have your hand
up
yeah thank you thank you for taking my
question I was just wondering if County
attorneys hearings and take
testimony I'm sorry you broke up just a
little bit and there I missed the middle
part of the question I'm sorry I was
just wondering if County attorneys hold
hearings and take
testimony uh so they would take
testimony as in part of a
prosecution um but that that would be
the extent of it thank
you any other
questions members here in the committee
room or
participating representative are you all
set still have your hand
up I'm seeing n um say thank you Miss
Oran thank
you anyone not seeing anyone on the list
of attendees who
wanted testify or any questions
sorry um
represent your hand do you want to
follow representative
or if you're talking to me I can't
really hear you yeah representative
board your hand is still up you have
another question I think you have to
take it down I do not have a question
all right all right representative
you're
ahead thank you Mr chair um I wondered
if I could just make a quick comment I
got a I was just alerted by a
constituent who's watching our our
hearings today um online that um a
reference was was made in testimony
earlier today about a hypothetical
fraudulent voter from
Islamabad um which you know would invoke
the notion that Muslims shouldn't be
thought of I guess as full citizens and
that you know I know is a false view
that everyone in this committee would um
certainly reject and I just wanted to uh
note that um thank you kindly
sir thank you
okay again I don't have anyone else to
testify on this
legislation and so I will be closing the
public hearing on House Bill
372 that concludes every um piece of
legislation that had been noticed in the
calendar for today March 4th to point
out that we are scheduled to reconvene
tomorrow morning um March 5th here at
9:30 with a uh
schedule of
legislation that all the business that I
know to come before the committee I will
adjourn thise meeting thank
you